as chair of the house Judiciary
Committee I find that due to the state
of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the Judiciary
Committee executive session on pending
legislation may be held please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this Mee
meeting by Zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a the right
to know law anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 that's
271-3600 or email
HCS l.st
.n. Us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and
rescheduled we do have one staff person
who will be monitoring the meeting
that's Jennifer for our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during the meeting shall
be done by roll call vote we'll begin
the meeting today by taking roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
under the right to no
law I'll begin by saying I'm Ned Gordon
I'm here at the legislative office
building with two other committee
members Mr clerk would you call the RO
representative uh I'm present uh in the
committee room at the L representative
syvia home alone in
Belmont is here representa represent
alander uh good morning I'm here in gown
house
silver
representative I'm here in my home in
wife representa
Kelly I am home alone in
Temple
representa
representative good morning I'm here at
my home in Belmont
alone representative Smith good morning
I'm uram
alone representative
uh good morning I'm in West Milan and
alone I'm I'm here I'm here in durm and
I don't even even have a Siri or an
alone good morning I'm here in my home
office in New Market and I'm alone in
the
myself can you speak to
us you hear me yes thank you sorry I'm
here alone in
Rollinsford
repres
good morning I'm here in Manchester and
my husband is in the house
representative
mes represent
PA good morning I'm in exitor uh
children in the
house representative
Simpson good morning I'm here in exitor
I'm alone in the room now my spouse and
day okay our first item of business
today is House Bill 149 FN an act
extending certain civil immunity to
public and private entities during major
public health
emergencies the
primary uh sponsor of this bill is
repres representative Stapleton and
representative Stapleton would you like
to introduce your
bill yes thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Walter Stapleton and I uh represent
Claremont ward 3 Sullivan County uh
District Five I bring you 149 FN house
bill um which is a affords a limited um
liability
immunity to um persons entities
businesses of All Sorts as defined in
the
bill when they act in good faith and in
observance of recommended Health Care
standards uh relative to uh National eem
or not National or state emeres as
declared by the governor or the
legislature um and yet are uh are being
sued um for the by persons who may have
attracted covid or other
diseases um it is uh the burden of proof
upon the person under this bill to prove
that they have contracted the covid or
other related diseases uh by virtue of
negligence um want and disregard
um or malicious or intentional
misconduct of the business or
entity um this bill came about um
from a constituent
request um business in Claremont that
was worried about uh um having
detrimental and frivolous lawsuits
levied against them um after already
having suffered the downturn of uh
economic activity and difficulty under
covid and I think that is may be shared
by many businesses that uh um suffered a
loss of reduction in business and yet
are fearful that they may get another
hit with the frivolous lawsuit by
someone who has contracted Co and then
bring that uh lawsuit to uh to the
business business for further
um trouble and and harassment um so the
bill is a
protection um against that type of
frivolous lawsuit
action and um what we what we did when
we started this back in um the
summertime we we had um legislative
Services look
into what was going on in other states
and at the time there were about 15
states that were already working on this
either by executive order Proclamation
by Governors and followed up by statutes
by the
legislators um I last night I did a a
quick abstract record of what was going
on to date and right now there are 48
states that have some
action um Rel relative to this very
subject um uh the District of
Columbia and uh only um only three
states have taken no action uh for covid
U uh imunity of liability that would be
Maine Washington and
Texas uh and of course New Hampshire
would be on that except that we have
this bill HP 149 and the Senate also has
come up with a similar Bill s
sp63 now just briefly my bill differs
from s sp63 and that sp63 is specific to
covid um whereas my bill um is targeted
for any um Health Emergency by declared
by uh the New Hampshire legislature or
the governor similar to what we have now
and that way uh we're not uh just
limited to the current covid
situation I'm thinking that we may have
more of these down the road in the
future either variations of covid um
that we're we're being talked about now
and or some other new threat um that we
have to deal with on a state basis and
or nationally so I was trying to get the
maximum mileage out of uh my bill by
making it a little more applicable on a
National Emergency
basis um relative to the other
states uh there were about 19 of
them that restricted their liability
immunity to spec to specifically
covid and specifically to Health Care
Facilities workers professions
volunteers and so
forth the remainder um are more
encompassing with um the immunity
extended to businesses persons
entities um as well as Health Care
Professionals businesses uh facilities
and so
forth the common theme among all of them
is the good faith principle which we've
adopted in this bill that if a
businessperson entity acts in good faith
to observe the orders statutes
directives uh of U the state the health
department
CDC
um the
uh the general guidelines of of other
applicable agencies then
they're afforded uh the presumption of
uh limited liability and Immunity to
that and this is not unlike what we
already have in the statute at
508 um we have about a dozen limited
liability
immunities um not unlike uh one of my
favorites is for instance the
landowner presumption of um Li um
immunity when um they open up their land
to public use for
trail uh without fee and they're immune
from liability except if they do
something that's un unsafe or
intentionally malicious so on and so
forth 508 colon representative stap I
want to cut you short but U we have a
lot of people who have signed up to
speak so if you could kind of wrap up it
would be appreciated yes sir um um and
so um I just wanted to draw attention to
that that we already have uh U the
liability uh
immunities um that uh are CH can be
challenged um if there is other than uh
faithful good faith efforts to observe
uh and keep the public safe at their
establishment or at their premis
so um with that I'll conclude um and and
leave time open for questions thank you
thank thank you for your testimony uh
representative uh first of all before uh
we do have some people with questions
but I just note to everybody that we
have 10 people who have signed up to
speak uh and and and I see another hand
up in addition to that so I am going to
limit the testimony at this point in
time to for other speakers to to uh
three minutes uh going
forward and representa Moran did you
have a question for representative
Stapleton oh sure yes um anytime anytime
through the court systems or any or
anywhere else when you provide a venue
where people can seek you know redress
for damages or that some people people
are going to take advantage of and that
may not always be unfol but you so I'm
not sure um and there already is course
there already course are some protect
sort protections for people who are
filing frivolous lawsuits and or against
people who aren't aren't acting in good
facei so
do and of course it um I did notice that
Texas was one of the states which
doesn't do it which of course is the
state that recently lifted its mass
mandate and but um so you have any
examples of any lawsuits privilege or
not that have in fact been U filed for
that would be that could potentially be
affected by this law I mean are there
any lawsuits here in hampire or even
elsewhere that you know of um where
they've been suing people because of um
because of
covid thank you for the question
representative Oregon um and that is a
good question um I have to say I'm sorry
that I have had not had time to
investigate that that would have been a
logical followup prior to my coming here
but I I have not been able to do that so
I'm not aware to what extent lawsuits
have been filed in any of the 48 states
and District of
Columbia representa
bir do you have a question thank you um
and thank you representative for taking
my question um first of all uh is it not
true that we already have in the law uh
lawsuits uh yes I'm sure that uh we we
have more than adequate statuto
Authority for dealing with these things
but we felt that um because of the
special nature um of of the covid uh
pandemic and the possibility of um
lawsuits arising out of that that might
be frivolous or baseless that we needed
some protection and and I think it Bears
out that concern is valid by virtue of
the 40
states that have enacted Governor's
proclamations statutory emergency orders
and so forth um so um yeah it's not
operating to the exclusion of those
other um statutes or orders but in
addition
to if I could follow up with just a very
quick question go ahead uh
representative you seem very numbers
oriented I'm wondering if you have the
number of states that have passed
legislation uh roughly equivalent to
legislation I use principally U several
of the states language that came very s
similar to each other in um the
observance of some good faith efforts to
comply with directives executive order
statutes CDC directives and so
forth
um but beyond that it's all over the
board um with regard to who was covered
that's the major variance is the
entities that are covered in all of
those 48 different
states but the common theme was um that
people acted in good faith without
malice and without wanting disregard
that uh they would be afforded a
rebuttable uh
uh your question thank you represent
representative Alexander did you have a
question um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
my my question is primarily around
section one of the bill lines 10 through
16 um I guess so it says like there's an
immunity for actual or alleged injury or
infection or exposure resulting from a
declared health health emergency but
then it says the immunity shall not to
apply in the case of willful negligence
wanting disregard or malicious or
intentional misconduct there's an
argument to be made that um you know not
wearing a mask whether it is you know
mandated by the governor or not would be
would qualify as a want and disregard or
malicious or um intentional misconduct I
guess I'm wondering um is there like an
example of you know
how this bill would you know further
protect people like that or or would do
something that isn't already covered in
statute well thank you for the question
that that is a good question because um
with regard to masks for instance the
jury seems to still be out in various
Circles of thought and even science um
there are some of course that say that
the mass can actually be harmful under
circumstances others say it's mandatory
to guard yourself other people
um you know the devil's in the details
but we could not address every possible
recommendation or circumstance uh
relative to PPE in the bill and none of
the states do that that have enacted
this type of legislation or executive
orders they've left it up basically to
uh the states the CDC the health
departments those experts and scientists
that can make the prescription
best thank you representative mlan yeah
thank you um so we are press for time so
we just give me a concise answer on this
one I'm just because this is not a
blanket immunity because it's a
qualified immunity of sorts there has to
be a violation of good faith in practice
how would this work who would determine
whether or not it was good faith without
first uh going to court so how how would
I I would suppose that um a lawsuit is
brought and it would have to appear to
uh to the court to make that judgment
and the motion by attorneys uh to
dismiss based on the
statute or to proceed based on the
evidence that there was a lack of good
faith U proper regard for uh the the
recommendations
thank you are there any other questions
for representative
stapon see none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you uh the next speaker will be also a
baldasaro um thank you Mr chairman U for
the record representative Al Bal DeSaro
Rockingham County District 5 London der
I'm here in an undisclosed location and
my wife is in the house but anyways I'm
be real quick um this is a protection
bill and it's being proactive um we know
what's on the books about frivolous
lawsuits and other things but the bottom
line is it's costing businesses it could
cost business money right up front in
lawyer feeds and then it's only my
understanding of the bill is only for
the covid um you know it wouldn't
protect it we already protect those
pharmaceutical companies that are giving
um shots vaccines to people they have
immunity so why shouldn't we be be
proactive in protecting our businesses
and that's all I have and I know you
guys got a lot of work to do thank you
very much are there any questions for
representative
baldasaro seeing none again thank you
for your testimony today thank
you next speaker will be uh Israel padra
representative
padra thank you Mr chair uh for the
record my name is Israel Pedra I
Hillsboro District 9 um which is
Manchester Ward 2 and I am speaking
today in opposition to this bill um by
way of disclosure I I I am a practicing
attorney as many of you know I represent
uh both plaintiffs and defendants in a
variety of litigation matters including
injury matters um there there's a couple
problems with this bill um the first
being that um it immunizes negligence
and that's kind of my biggest objection
to it and I to the extent this committee
continues to hear bills that attempt to
um protect for profit businesses from
the consequences of their own negligence
I will continue to testify in opposition
to them um simply put this bill will
would allow negligent businesses which
negligently injure their customers to
avoid
repercussions um under current law I
think it's important to point out a
business is only going to be legally
liable if they are negligent that's the
current law that's that's how uh the law
of torts Works you're not liable someone
gets covid on your property you're not
liable just because one of your
employees gives covid to one of your
customers you're only liable if you were
negligent and it is proved that you
caused injury due to your
negligence um so there's no statute
that's necessary to protect a business
from non-negligent
behavior um I think it's important to
point out uh that to my knowledge and to
my understanding from to others knowledg
is that there have been no such lawsuits
in New Hampshire relating to covid
injuries um I'm not aware of a single
one National organizations track this
kind of thing and they're not aware of
any such lawsuit in New Hampshire um so
really this is a solution in search of a
problem um and in that regard I mean the
entire purpose of our justice system is
that folks get to bring their claims
into court and a jury of New Hampshire
citizens decide whether that claim is
valid that's what's been done for
hundreds of
years um I think the bill the second
issue with the bill is its language and
it um the structure of it frankly it's
very vague um it applies to um uncertain
things in the future first of all it
also talks about uh willful negligence
which in in my mind is kind of a
oxymoron and not really a appropriate
term for for for a bill negligence as
many of you know is by definition
something that's an accident um willful
on the other hand implies intent so to
the extent the the bill talks about
willful
negligence um it doesn't necessarily
mean what you think it means uh I I
believe it would be interpreted as
someone uh intentionally injuring
someone else uh due to due to covid or
causing spread of Co intentionally
essentially um
so the the the language of the bill is I
think too imprecise um to really be
workable I think as as uh a Committee
Member pointed out the language is also
vague enough that um whether a business
actually complies in good faith or with
government regulations is not actually
something that is going to be decidable
by a judge that's a question that a jury
is ultimately going to decide if there's
any centella of evidence um um you know
in favor of the plaintiff so to the
extent that this bill is designed to
prevent lawsuits from coming in the door
from going to a jury it's not going to
succeed um because ultimately whether
the language of the statute has been
complied with is going to be a question
for the jury so in my opinion just to
conclude yeah if you could just wrap up
please I I I will wrap up yep just just
in my opinion to to conclude I think
that this is a bill that seeks to have
the legislature dictate who gets access
to the courthouse I think it's
paternalistic it's activist it's
unnecessary most of all okay um so thank
you very much for for your for your time
thank you representative Soviet did you
have a question for representative P yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just a brief one uh
with the spread of a virus like we have
here uh what are the chances you could
possibly track down where you got it
from as as a lawyer bringing a suit um
what's the difficulty involved
there I thank you representative for
your question I think that's a very
important Point thank you for bringing
it up um and that you're precisely right
being able to track where a covid
infection was incurred I think would be
extremely and prohibitively difficult
and that's the exact reason why we
haven't seen covid related lawsuits in
New Hampshire and we likely won't see
them it's because under a neg regular
neg claim under the current law not you
need to show that your injury was caused
by the defendant and part of that cause
is showing that you contracted the
infection um more likely than not from
that Source I think that's next to
impossible to prove under current law
and another reason why we don't need
this thank you thank you any other
questions for representative
P see none thank you for your testimony
today
Creer hi thank you for letting me speak
today um my name is David career I am
director of public policy for the
business and industry Association of New
Hampshire uh we are very supportive of
this bill as well as the other ones um
that have been mentioned prior to this
um so one of the top issues among our
businesses is this Safe Harbor
protections uh they are afraid that
while they're operating during the
pandemic they will face lawsuits uh from
people claiming they've contracted
covid-19 at that business um and these
cases you know has already been implied
have going to be very difficult to
approve uh and even if successful well
that business still has to pay 3040
$50,000 uh to defend itself um because
everyone pays their own attorney fees
for the most part uh in the US um so I
want to say uh kind of a point that was
made up um yeah even though these cases
will be hard to win uh even if winning
that business still has to pay that
money while they're already struggling
from the coronavirus pandemic uh I also
want to mention that this law would only
apply to those businesses following
state and federal guidelines for
operating during the pandemic um and uh
so the issue that was brought up about
immunizing negligence well if you're not
following the uh state or federal
guidelines well yeah you can be sued and
you should be um even in the eyes of you
know the Bia um you know we're not going
to protect Bad actors here this is just
people are businesses who are uh doing
their best to help prevent the spread of
covid-19 just like everybody else um
it's been asked how many have been filed
uh over 200 lawsuits of this type have
been filed across the country uh none
have been filed in New Hampshire yet um
but there is a three-year statute of
limitations in New Hampshire so it could
happen um at some point um and I also
want to bring up that if there are never
going to be lawsuits filed in the state
well then passing the bill does no harm
there's no issue with doing it those
lawsuits never would have been filed
anyway but if they would have been filed
and could have put a business this law
could prevent businesses um from having
to pay these excessive legal fees and uh
putting that business uh down
permanently I also want to address um a
couple issues I think uh representative
Burj asked about frivolous lawsuits uh
the burden to meet uh frivolous lawsuit
to get into those penalties is pretty
high um and so what ends up happening is
a person could sue a company for
$20,000 uh claiming damages from covid
but if it cost $30,000 to defend well
the business has to pay they're going to
make that decision to just pay out the
settlement well then the next person
comes and the next person and it's it's
really this bill will help prevent that
from ever occurring in the first place
uh and my last Point here I know we got
a short on time um it was asked about uh
States and how many other states have
passed similar laws uh by my research 19
other states have already passed similar
legislation to this uh and another 17
other than New Hampshire are currently
considering those laws as well thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative haran did you have a
question for Mr queer uh well yes uh I
noticed um in the language in this bill
like in the paragraph two of the part
it's intended apply only to protect
businesses but it does also apply to
individuals so would you want to clarify
the law to make sure that we're only
protecting uh business you know persons
other than natural persons that is
businesses and other institutions
individuals or are you happy with the
language as is thank
you um yeah that's a great question uh
we're happy with the language as is um
you know it's not just an issue
obviously I represent businesses so
that's uh where my testimony comes from
but this would affect you know schools
places of worship uh public parks you
know so the municipalities or any you
know thing that building that they own
that's open to the public really any uh
place where public can gather could see
themselves uh facing these types of
lawsuits representative McLean uh yeah
thank you Mr chair just quickly Mr queer
um back to my earlier question uh who
makes the determination of good faith as
to whether or not the the case can go
forward that's that's a decision that
has to be made and it can't be made by
the party so under this law who makes
that determination and how would that
happen uh it's great question um I will
preface this by saying that I am not a
trial attorney I've never done
litigation uh but my understanding would
be that if that business is following
all of the state and federal guidelines
then it's pretty clear that they were
acting in good faith to follow them
because they were in fact following them
uh and that could be made by a judge uh
in summary judgment now if they were
lacking in specific Provisions you know
like they didn't require masks or
something like that um then that would
have to have a little bit more Discovery
in order to determine whether or not was
acting in good faith but I think you
know
99.9% of businesses are following all of
the guidance so it would be a pretty
easy clear determination that could be
made by a judge thank you representative
good thank thank you uh any other
questions for Mr
career seeing none thank you for your
testimony today great thank you next
testimony would be uh person to testify
Woodberry good morning Mr chair thank
you for letting me speak today good
morning members of the committee can you
hear me okay you
can thank you very much um so I I wanted
to uh first say that um well well first
my name is Bill Woodbury and I am a
practicing attorney in T New Hampshire
uh and um I also serve as legislative
chair for the New Hampshire Association
for justice um I rise in opposition to
this
bill uh I would like to uh indicate that
I would Echo the comments made by
representative uh
Pedra and would incorporate them into my
own in full um but uh given the limited
time I just want to kind of address um
you know what representative Stapleton
and representative CER have have stated
I'm sorry Mr CER have rep have
represented here regarding that you know
businesses are are worried um and I
think that you know this worry is is is
fostered by this kind of um
uh this
persistent um you know Spectre of
frivilous lawsuits that just doesn't
bear out in the state of New Hampshire
um as uh Mr CER and Mr Stapleton I think
uh agreed there are there have been no
cases filed in the state of New
Hampshire and Mr CER indicated that
there were 200 lawsuits Nationwide I
don't know that that is I don't know if
that's the correct number or not but I
do know that um you know of that have
been filed 96 are in California 50 are
in New York and then you know another
smattering throughout the country but
none in the state of New Hampshire and
they're not being filed because these
are cases that as uh Israel Pedra
indicated you know it would be
exceedingly difficult um to prove um and
the expense to an attorney who takes on
one of these cases who would have to
front the the uh expenses for experts
and things like that would be extreme um
David CER you know talked about somebody
fing a lawsuit for $20,000 or something
like that that would never occur the
expert fees alone in a in a case of this
nature could likely exceed that number
you would be hiring medical doctors
epidemiologists it would be exceedingly
difficult to bring one of these cases
and that's why you're not seeing them
and that's why you're not going to see
them um and um I want to address the the
the good faith comment that um Mr Cryer
made um with respect to good faith you
know he indicated that good faith would
be following the guidelines well um
currently the current law as
representative Pedra mentioned the
current law um is that if one is
negligent um then they are going to be
liable potentially liable for someone's
injuries and negligence is about acting
unreasonably if you're acting reasonably
you're not going to be found to be
negligent if your three are up if you
could wrap up that would be great I I
will I I guess my uh my main point is
that this as uh representative Pedra
indicated is um
a a solution in search of of a problem
it's it's
unconstitutional it undermines part one
article 14 you thank you for your
testimony are there any questions for
Woodburry seeing none thanks for your
testimony today thank you Mr
chairman uh and I look call upon is
here
hello yes can you hear
me try try to stay within your three
minutes if you can I'll try can you guys
hear me okay we can okay great so my
name's Michael dears I'm the owner of
CCI managed services in Claremont um I
worked with Walt uh it was my concern
that got him uh to start looking into
this and I appreciate all your time um
I've got 20 employees uh we've been in
business over 30 years uh we provide
critical IT services mostly Hampshire
Vermont but we have clients in five
other states um my my concern stems from
um the Spectre of lawsuits primarily you
know where're we understand that there's
uh you
know that that the reality is that there
uh may not be a lot of lawsuits being
won on this but the the possibility of
just being sued and having 203 $50,000
law uh suit cost just to defend yourself
that type of cost is is what's keeping
me up at night um I know in working with
almost a 100 customers that are
organizations and businesses this is a
topic of conversation and most other
business owners feel the same way um so
it may not necessarily be I I think the
reality is we're dealing with something
that um is creating a lot of fear um
about litigation um even if that
litigation does not result in in uh in
actually having to to pay um as the as
the defendant most likely would would
would be looking at legal fees and
probably not more than that um on a
personal note I also belong to a 12-step
program um and uh here in Claremont we
had over a 100 members and and uh we
were all meeting in a in a local church
basement you know for five six seven
meetings a week um you know this is
important stuff for those of us that
that need to do that and um I just want
you to know that th that church uh
closed its doors to to our group uh a
year ago and has refused to reopen them
and they they're citing liability
concerns that's their concern so whether
this is something that is uh real or not
um the reality in in on the street is
that um you know you're you're going to
have those types of things happening
when people are in fear of being sued
over covid liability a bill like this
could could help to uh open those doors
up again and get people the help they
need um and that I think is a really
important uh side issue so thank you for
your time thank you Mr dears are there
any questions from Mr
dears
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony
today call upon Chris
[Music]
sufer all right is this
working it does all right good morning
morning Christopher suf of suf Law
Offices here in Franklin New Hamp
I'll be brief I practiced law since 1984
general Practice in this little city
some of you know me I'm a pretty
straight shooter I know that your your
chairman there um he's a pretty good
lawyer tried some cases with him before
he became a judge and then when he was a
judge practiced in his court every year
and always had the pleasure and the
courts are where on New Hampshire
Constitution says we resolve disputes
part one article 14 of our New Hampshire
Constitution says legal remedies are to
be free complete and prompt and every
subject of this state is entitled to a
certain Remedy by having recourse to the
laws part one article 20 says in all
controversies over
$1,500 the party shall have a right to a
trial by jury this method of procedure
shall be held sacred so so my businesses
are dealing with the same covid-19
problems as every other business we got
problems with revenue losses Child Care
issues employees working remotely but
none of my business clients none of them
have come to me and said that threatened
to be
sued none of my clients have come to me
and said they want to sue a business
because of covid-19 related issues so
while we hear all of the Doomsday
predictions by the proponents where's
the proof of need to strip our New
Hampshire citizens of their New
Hampshire constitutional rights so
here's my
summary almost four Decades of practice
in law New Hampshire businesses and
individuals just need to act
reasonably if you act reasonably that's
all the the Hampshire law
requires the 2012 New Hampshire Supreme
Court case of Tom Morgan gives an
excellent summary of the New Hampshire
standards on reasonableness the very
moral fabric of a civilized society is
summed up in their
words responsibility for personal
malens runs through all relations of
individuals each of us to the other what
this bill would do is remove that moral
Fabric and allow Bad actors to act
unreasonably unless it can be proven
that they acted willful wanting
malicious and intentional I ask that you
not pass this bill and thank you for
your time this
morning thank you very much for your
testimony and are there any questions
suur seeing none thank you
Von good morning
um this is uh for the record um I am
Nancy vaugh government relations
director for the American Heart
Association in New Hampshire and I'm
providing testimony and support of House
Bill 149 um so I do have written
testimony that I submitted um so I will
be brief and really just point out um a
couple of paragraphs from that um the
health and safety of people and their
families is always the American Heart
association's top priority people with
underlying health conditions including
our heart and stroke survivors are among
those at highest risk for complications
and death from covid-19 since the
pandemic we have chosen to not hold
volunteer meetings or fundraising events
in person as safety measures for our
volunteers and employees even as
vaccinations roll out and we are again
hosting events the American Heart
Association will continue with health
safety protocols when the time does come
to resume imperson events we appreciate
the liability protections House Bill 149
would provide should either the co 19
pandemic or another Public Health
Emergency be present the prospect of
litigation and the exorbitant legal
costs is unnerving to organizations like
ours um and even a deterrent to
reopening um such litigation could
devastate entities just beginning to
reopen their doors and even those who
have remained open throughout this
recent crisis covid-19 has had a
devastating impact on nonprofit
organizations like the American Heart
Association because of the fact that we
have been doing remote fundraising
events um uh the threat of frivolous
lawsuits is a real concern and
nonprofits like the American hard
Association who are following and
maintaining safety guidelines and need
protection to safely maintain business
House Bill 149 would not extend
liability protection to Shield gross
negligence or willful misconduct um I
also want to just um make reference to
um an example that we have here in New
Hampshire um many years ago the uh the
the um the state did provide limited
liability for Good Samaritans who
perform CPR on total strangers um and
several years um uh ago well almost 20
years ago the um the state also passed
um limited liability for automated
external defibrillator use um also known
as aeds this um liability protection was
also extended to the owners of the aeds
as well as the users of the aeds and
basically what this did there were no
lawsuits at the time that the this law
was passed um but we needed to um help
businesses and others who should have
aeds not fear frivolous um lawsuits um
and so what this did in the end is it
did encourage more aeds to be out in the
community um so saving lives so in um in
conclusion I just want to say that we we
again are in support of House Bill 149
um uh charitable entities are list
listed in this um in the language to the
bill and we definitely appreciate that
and I urge you to uh to pass the Bill
thank you very
much repres representative Smith I saw
up thank you Mr chair I decided um there
was no reason to ask a question in light
of how long this uh hearing is going
thank you representative Horgan okay
I'll try make this quick um I saw your
letter um V it sounds like you're me the
primary concern a year ago is not uh the
fear of being sued so much as a fear of
you know your volunteers or your staff
people you know catching uh catching
covid which and suffering the obviously
Spar health things and dying so your
your support for this bill at this point
mostly looking forward your fear getting
sued so you are viewing this different
now that
um we have vaccines we have somewhat
effective treatments masks are available
and widely used Etc so are you is your
fear of lawsuits um looming larger now
that the maybe the safety concerns are
not quite as uh severe as they were a
year ago when this whole crisis started
yep yes um thank you for your question
um yes when we we closed down it was
because we were being responsible um
stewards for our our volunteers um now
it is really the open reopening concerns
and while vaccinations are rolling out
it vaccinations will just protect the
person being vaccinated they can still
pass transmit virus onto others if they
are not wearing face masks and with what
we're we're hearing people are ready to
dispense with wearing face masks and
that is something that we will continue
requiring um but we can't control
everyone's Behavior so thank
you follow up so the the lawsuit are
your it's just secondary concern your
main concern is the safety of the of the
people you're you're working with either
virtually or in person so just one yes
our main concern is always our our our
volunteers um donors and staff thank
you thank you any other questions for
Miss
Von seeing them again thank you for your
testimony the next person is Tony
skini and I hope I pronounced that
correctly
y hello my name is Anthony skull I'm a
lawyer in nashwa a firm Gillan skull and
brini and I have uh two things I just
want to briefly mention they deal with
the logistics and the finances of AOSS
so one thing that I've heard from a lot
of people is the issue of lawyers fees
uh it's most of the most of the time
cases are brought uh when there is some
insurance defense firm on the other side
and I say that because if it's a if it's
a small business and they have very few
assets and the case itself involves you
know relatively low damage it's
generally not financially viable for a
lawyer to take that case because they're
taking those cases on a contingency fee
which means that the lawyer pays out all
of the expert costs and then recovers
those costs plus his fee only if he
collects so if there's no you know if
the damages are low like the one example
that was given a $20,000 lawsuit no
one's going to take that case because of
the financial requirements in bringing a
contingency fee case on an issue as
difficult to track as covid-19 uh one
other point I wanted to talk about is
this idea about how this immunity would
operate so the gentleman from The
Business Association talked about how
this would work and I think that what we
need to focus on here is the the steps
in the process so a motion to dismiss
can be filed for some sort of uh formal
or procedural flaw if we're talking
about an issue where there's no factual
dispute and only a dispute about what
the law means then that's appropriately
determined at subing judgment which is
done after discovery if we're talking
about determining whether or not
somebody followed a good faith
requirement that's almost certainly a
factual dispute and that would get
settled by a jury so as written this
bill would not provide the immunities
that people think it would because the
way in which lawsuits are dismissed is
based largely on the kind of dispute it
is and by including this good faith
exception you're all but guaranteeing
that the issue goes all the way to a
jury so I think that this law this law
is unnecessary you can go to cracker.com
and see that there are zero lawsuits in
New Hampshire I think the idea that it
would provide some sort of Sav for the
fears that people have is misleading
because of the way in which lawsuits are
dismissed and I think that the financial
viability of covid lawsuits is largely
going to prohibit any of them from being
brought in the state of New Hampshire
and so I am an opposition of this Bill
thank you for your testimony and are
there any uh questions for attorneys
krini seeing none again thank you again
for your Tes
the last person who pre-registered to
Chase go forward C can you hear me you
can okay great good morning
Representatives thank you for allowing o
me the time to speak I know it's already
been a long morning um for the record my
name is Marissa Chase I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice a Statewide
Association of trial attorneys uh
representing um a wide array of
practices in New Hampshire we have about
400 members Statewide if there are any
legal questions you or any of your
constituents may have I can probably
find an answer um so I just wanted to
reiterate we are in opposition to this
bill I did send written testimony which
I will will not repeat um I just want to
make a few key points liability is
accountability the only thing anyone or
any business needs to do to not be sued
is to act as a reasonable person would
under the circumstances and I want to
reiterate under the same circumstances
because that's a kind of flexibility
that has evolved in our common law that
lends our common law to situations like
this pandemic our tort system has been
in effect since the late 1700s attorney
suur mentioned the New Hampshire
Constitution which the only time time
the word sacred is mentioned in the New
Hampshire Constitution is when is an
article um part one article it's either
14 or 20 that talks about your right to
a jury trial of your
peers um and I just wanted to um kind of
respond to some of the comments made um
by an earlier speaker about other
immunities this legislature has granted
and I would respectfully disagree that
providing CPR and reopening a business
safely should be equated in law as you
know for a Good Samaritan a I think if
people are you
know if a person is providing necessary
Health Care to someone they're probably
more worried about saving that person's
life not about being sued which is how
we should all act um and I just don't
think that those two situations should
be equated and if a business can't
reopen safely you know I would
respectfully say that just based on
societal health is shouldn't that be the
top concern not just focused on
liability but that kind of tells me that
you need liability because liability
lends itself to accountability in making
sure that everybody knows the rules and
plays by the rules the language in this
bill is very vague um not knowing what
rules to follow it's not really clear um
again representative padra said earlier
willful negligence our civil justice
system does not recognize degrees of
negligence in New Hampshire there's
negligence and there's not um you'll
find other statutes and criminal codes
that talk about mental States but that's
not in our civil justice system and one
last thing I just want to say that
insurance companies defend businesses
that's why businesses pay liability
policy coverage I don't know of a single
liability policy that covers intentional
acts and that is the only case if a bill
like this were to pass that a business
would actually be on the hook for
defending a claim against it because
under our current structure insurance
companies defend a business the business
does not have to hire their own defense
attorney that's why they pay insurance
but if a liability policy does not cover
an intentional act they will tell the
business not our policy you're out of
luck um so I will wrap up and just say I
hope that you um vote this bill itl
there are a couple other proposals House
Bill 255 currently in House Education
Senate Bill 63 which the Senate just
voted 21-3 yesterday to re-refer so if
this issue is of concern you'd like to
talk further I sent you all an email you
have my contact information please don't
hesitate to be in touch and thank you
very much for your time thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
for Miss
Chase sigan thank you very much and
there are two people I see that have
their hands raised who wish to testify
and hopefully they can add something
that something new to our discussion
today the first person is Chris
kellerer
ker then since we don't seem to be able
to make the connection then call upon
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak up Mr shair um I'm calling an
opposition of this bill um I I have
respect for like small businesses and
the business our communities but one
thing I don't agree is if the business
is being um not following the procedures
especially during uh emergency orders
and an emergency situation like the one
we we have right now with the pandemic I
don't believe this bill it should be
passed because we need we need someone
to keep the businesses online like make
sure that they follow the procedures um
to be honest myself I
witness uh some some of the businesses
local businesses for instance I went to
a gas station and someone didn't wasn't
wearing a mask and I was wearing a mask
and someone else was wearing a mask and
the other person asked the person on the
gas station working at the gas station
why this person is allowed here without
wearing a mask and he say well I'm not
going to ask the person to wear a mask
how about how about that the rest of the
people in that gas station um so we we
that person put the rest of the people
into rest and then that business can be
uh accountable as someone get sick so I
I don't believe this bill should be
passed because we need to keep the
business accountable to make sure that
people don't get sick uh in another
instance my husband he's an electrician
and he works in different areas like
commercial uh residential and Industrial
and then they always has to wear masks
they has to follow the procedures if uh
if they don't follow the procedures you
know they they they can they can they
you know they that that's when the
people you know they can get concerned
and get a lawsuit but if you follow the
procedures I don't think it's necessary
to have this law okay thank thank you
for your testimony are there any
questions for representative
Perez seeing none thank you and one more
shot for Chris kellerer if Chris
unmute I don't uh and that that
concludes the
testimony
on House
Bill 149 we'll close the hearing on
House Bill
149 we'll move on to the house bill open
the hearing on House Bill 402 and I note
that no one signed up to speak on House
Bill 402 Mr
chair Mr chair could you just tell us
what the count is on the blue sheet for
149 I can thank you there were nine in
support and 57 in opposition thank
you and
on house go 402 which we're about to
hear there were seven in support and
eight in
opposition but our own representative
Sylvia is the sponsor on House Bill 402
and I would call upon representative
Sylvia to introduce the bill you would
like to do
so thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee members for uh listening to my
brief introduction of this bill we'll
get you back on schedule right quickly
uh this this bill is very simple and at
the same time probably uh considered
very extreme by some
folks
um this bill
simply uh puts a very very high barrier
to the takings of property under a state
of
emergency
um one of the things that I love about
our state
constitution is
the fact that it was written with the
people's rights in part
first and before they even
considered creating a government they
spelled out what the government did not
need and that includes all of our rights
and particularly
uh property
rights is the foundation of
everything at least in uh
um see that way um so this bill
requires uh beyond the governor and
executive Council it requires the
legislature to vote by two-thirds to
approve the
takings now I did it this way because
um outright uh repealing this section of
code um would have been perhaps a little
more difficult as though this is going
to be easy
U there are some
attachments uh in in other parts of the
code that get back to this um and having
to do with corpses and real
emergencies I think the fact that we
went uh 218 years until 2002 to
Institute this uh these whole emergency
Powers uh speaks to the lack of
necessity of any of
it and uh frankly I would repeal all of
it and we could just go back to pre2
2002 and be even more normal so that's
that's where I'm at I am an extremist
when it comes to our Constitution and
the rights of the people need to be
defended by government and not in
fringed by government thank you very
much for listen to My Testimony thank
you representative Morgan have a
question for representative s Oh indeed
I do um were there
any takings of real of personal property
that happened uh during the crisis of
the last year which been would have been
needed legislative approval by super
majority if uh your bill had been in
place uh for
2020 I am not aware of any takings uh
2002 followup yes you
may um as a practical matter how would
we obtain the ascent of two-thirds of
the Senate the House of Representatives
um if we had a future crisis which made
it unsafe for the legislature to meet in
its usual uh in rep Hall and the Senate
chamber um which the Senate has solved
but we haven't and also what if this
happens U when the legislature is not in
session thank you well exactly that is
perfectly the point of why we should
return to pre2 2002 what would have
happened pre2 2002 and what would happen
in the state of a real emergency
and I don't want to diminish the the the
deaths that have occurred because of Co
but uh you know we have heard testimony
of possible real emergencies we won't
need to get into gory details of things
that would cause perhaps not even the
executive Council to be able to meet uh
perhaps the governor would be part of
the emergency and not be there at all uh
these things are not things that we can
plan
for we can do the best we can and the
fact that the matter is the governor
will do what the governor is going to do
if there's an emergency and that's the
kind of leadership we have to accept but
it
becomes a question after the fact of was
it appropriate measures or not and what
are the consequences if not
would representative Smith did you have
a question
yes thank you very much Mr chair uh
representative Sylvia I'm trying to
follow as I always do um your thinking
and I wonder if you could help me
understand
why or how you would differentiate
between the Govern the government's
taking of
property and the government involving
itself in
uh yeah I I I'm I'm afraid I I would
have to sit and think on that long and
hard that's fine then uh uh representa
syvia no one could ask for anything more
than each of us thinks think about our
positions so I thank you for
bur uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
as I understand
already that uh such
takings uh with
compensation uh already would have to be
approved by the governor and the
executive councel uh this would add the
further approval
of a super majority of the legislature
given we're talking about an
emergency where fast action by
definition is
required um how do you see that working
let's say there's a a flood in in
conquered and um there needs to be or or
we can go back to seab Brook uh melting
down uh and there's a need for the
Department of Public Safety to step in
and Commander some some property perhaps
and the like how do you see that really
working in terms of getting the
legislature together and debating and
voting well I once again I I think it
your question really speaks to the flaw
in the statute as it sits and why it
frankly ought not be there um any of
these possible situations that we can
dream up might need a reaction within uh
an hour and is the the governor and
executive Council going to meet within
an hour and and take this issue up it's
it's not it's not saying uh that the the
whole statute just doesn't uh doesn't
have any reason to
it thank you
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question representative
Sylvia um could you
describe what the word taking in this
sentence
means well taking is is
uh removing uh someone's property from
them um and there are uh a couple of
different ways that that happens if we
look at the
statute
um me while I'm searching my
me
so in in the statute it it speaks of
taking uh possession of private real
estate and
improvements or it also speaks of taking
title and destroying some possible piece
of property so those are a couple of
methods of of takings
uh possibly temporary or possibly uh
forever if you are destroying something
so those are a couple of the ways that
the takings happen thank
you any other questions for
representative
syvia saying none thank you for your
testimony thank you very much is there
anyone else who desires to speak today
on House Bill 402 if if you do please
hand see no hands we will close the
hearing on house
42 the next hearing is House Bill
542 I note that 284 people signed up in
support
79 signed up in opposition but there are
22 people who have signed up to
speak and so I think what and and as I
go down through the list most of them
limited their the amount of time that
they wanted to speak to uh two minutes
or or not at all but um and and a couple
did three minutes and I think one person
did five minutes but I think I'm going
to just limit the testimony to two
minutes given the fact that we have so
many people who do wish to testify hear
from everybody so we will limit the
testimony to the two-minute period of
time
the uh
of representa is representative Aon and
representative Aon would you like to
introduce your
bill yes uh thank you uh Mr chair and
Ladies and Gentlemen of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony I
signed up for three minutes I'll try to
keep it two to two
um we we live in an interesting part of
the world in New Hampshire and New
England because a lot of the original
migration from Europe to this part of
the world uh was driven by uh this issue
of religious freedom and uh so the
original bill I'll speak to that first
um and then you should have gotten an
email yesterday with an amendment that
merges uh the original 542 in with the
original House Bill
440 uh I'm Prime sponsor on
542 I'm a co-sponsor on representative
kofalt Bill 440 um and I'll get into
that those details in a minute but uh
whether or not you are a religious
person and whether or not you are a
practicing religious person you benefit
and we all benefit by living in a
society that gives wide
deference to religion and the issue is
not religion the issue is your freedom
of
conscience that's really the issue and
that that can uh that freedom can
include believing in a deity believing
in no deity uh or having uh different
beliefs and the state stays clear of
your internal uh belief system when it
comes to uh religion the label we give
this for
religion um societies that where the
government imposes restrictions on
religion tend to be authoritarian uh
societies government uh somehow
government sees the concept of God as a
competing idea and tries to crush it or
tries to keep it
constrained um and you see that in uh
you know communist China where they're
taking down crosses on churches or
they're forcing churches to put a
picture of Ma in the back of the church
or they're rewriting the Bible so that
it fits with commun
um
Doctrine so when the state of emergency
took place here in New Hampshire we had
an interesting
situation that I think is unprecedented
I don't know if it's happened before in
New Hampshire or even in our country and
that's when the government uh for a
period of time period of uncertainty uh
shut down
churches and so that was a uh an
interesting moment in time and that
prompted the original idea a for House
Bill
542 to make sure that uh houses of
worship had had their uh their deserved
carv out in the state of emergency uh
rsas so you see that in House Bill
544 or 542 I'm sorry uh and that's uh
line 10 on the on the original Bill to
guarantee the free exercise of religion
the right of people to peacefully
assemble and talks about the first
amendment in the Constitution and uh
Article 5 part one Article 5 in the New
Hampshire Constitution which contain the
free exercise
clause uh I could probably go on a lot
more than uh two minutes so I'm gonna
skip over some of the things I'd like to
say um we already have so I have okay
I'll try to wrap it up it's a big topic
so the amendment Amendment
0623 take takes the original 440 Bill
and combines it with 542 so the original
[Music]
um can be
found on page
four line
24 so that's the kernel of the original
542 the rest of the language is from the
original 440 bill and if you recall back
when there was testimony on 440 with
representative Kofa uh he put that bill
in before the Mac decision that came
from the US Supreme Court that dealt
with the exercise of free or the free
exercise of religion and it it gave a uh
a strong statement on what New
Hampshire's free exercise clause means
and that it's much stricter than what
the federal government's Clause means
so that bill was
removed and that that bill was amended
but there's there's been discussions
that we should codify the Mac decision
in state law and that's what the
original 440 did so that's the the uh
the impetus behind the amendment is to
combine
542 protecting religious exercise uh
during state of emergency combining it
with
440 they're completely related subjects
so that we put the Mac decision statute
already spoken about four minutes here
so if you could just wrap up that would
be
appreciated well set okay rep
representative Horan did you have a
question yes I just wondering um is
there constitutional issue here on
giving privileges to overtly religious
organizations as opposed to other uh
other organizations like atheist groups
or let's say just hypothetically I had a
study group which gets together every
week to study critical race Theory um so
would you uh so is that a you feel that
maybe something NE so do you have a
problem with the bill is written um
carving out religious groups from other
uh other people discussing sort
non-religious Phil philosophical topics
you know thank
you uh if you consider your study group
or religion then I think maybe it might
apply but if it's a academic study group
then you that would be a different realm
Over
Law representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair thank
you represent Ammon um my question is
regarding um like ways people can abuse
this um if it's enacted so um say over
the summer I decide I want to have a
barbecue with a bunch of my friends
during a state of emergency and you know
I have a bunch of people over my house
um and we read you know a verse of the
Bible would that would that
qualify as a um like an opportunity for
free assembly if I you know we just
maybe read one or two verses then
continue on with our
day could you elaborate on that scenario
I mean what what kind of enforcement
would you expect to happen in that
situation I guess I guess that's my
question is is could this could this be
construed or abused um you know in a
situation like that so that would apply
to narrow Tailoring so if you look at
the
bill uh it's page 4 line 12 and
13 so that would be the test that the
government would apply to what you're
doing
um and it you know is is there an
essential and uh compelling interest of
the government and what is the least
restrictive means of furthering that
compelling interest so you know if
you're actually having a Bible study
that might happen to have a barbecue at
the end uh it the government would have
to use the least restrictive means to
enable your free exercise of
religion that's very helpful thank you
thank
you representative
bur uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representa for taking my question um I
thought I heard you uh
suggest that this uh under covid was the
first time that the uh churches uh were
closed during the pandemic um I said to
my to my knowledge I said okay were you
aware that during the
1918 influenza pandemic churches were
closed
worldwide do you have a reference for
that so I can look it up uh just Google
uh churches closed 1918 pandemic you'll
see lots of Articles and and the
government closed the churches or did
they voluntarily close well that I don't
know
all
represent seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you very
much next person testify is Ken
don't don't see
him then
um next person to testify would be
there
hand don't um I don't see that
[Music]
person the uh we'll call upon I'm going
to indicate that uh everybody who has
signed up has signed up uh the all the
remaining speakers who have signed up
have signed up in
support
so
if and so we will hold people to that
two minute and I'm sure we'll
get everybody in at some point in time
GRE Jeffrey
gree good morning Mr chairman and
members of the Judiciary Committee I'm
representative Jeff gson of Wentworth I
would gladly add my name as a co-sponsor
of this bill if I could so thank you for
allowing me a couple of minutes to
express my support in House Bill 542 the
events of the past year have
demonstrated that government tends
toward expansion and abuse of its powers
and will infringe on people's rights if
it is not constantly held in check and
if we allow government to use the excuse
of an emergency to infringe upon rights
than emergencies they will give us I
personally know three pastors who
directly face such infringements in the
past year one of whom was fined
$112,000
it didn't matter that people remained in
their cars it didn't matter if Services
were being held outside it didn't matter
that reasonable care was being taken to
protect people inside and out there was
an attempt by government to shut down
god-given constitutionally protected
rights in the name of an emergency and
it was one of the very first actions
taken by government going as far as to
label Church attendance as super
spreader events thus stoking fear and
panic and bigotry against those who
would attend church services in person
these pastors were not uh excuse me
these pastors were put in a situation
that no Pastor or Christian or anybody
wants to be in having to decide between
obeying government or obeying God their
decisions were not made with any malice
and there was they were prepared for the
consequences but the decision of the
government to go after these pastors was
arbitrary capricious and abusive because
no police was ever sent to the local
Walmarts or Home Depot that routinely
have larger attendance indoors than
these churches and liquor stores
remained open no government should be so
comfortable wanly trampling on people's
rights even under the guise of an
emergency the Constitution does not
limit what the people can do it limits
what the government can do including
during emergencies we should not need
this law but we do the courts got it
right this time in reminding Governors
and other officials about religious
freedom but the meanings of the words of
the US and the New Hampshire
Constitution and other state
constitutions have become increasingly
more vague and the citizens of this
country have been found to not have
standing in our own courts with greater
frequency next time is not worth the
risk region is found in the in the First
Amendment because it is one of the first
things that tyrannical governments take
away so please send House Bill 542 to
the floor with a unanimous OTP
recommendation so that regardless of of
your faith lack of faith you'll be free
to exercise it without infringement even
during an emergency thank you thank you
represent Horgan did you have a question
oh I I guess so yes um you mentioned the
pastor who was fined even though he had
a drive-in service
and that particular story but was that
Pastor taking the precautions that he
did um simply out of fear of uh fear of
the government or was he doing it
primarily out of fear of the of the
pandemic and
I the pastor's name is Charles Hamilton
at King James Bible Baptist Church in
Greenville Mississippi he's actually a
personal friend of mine and in in trying
to accommodate all of the uh uh the
guidelines trying to follow uh what
would be considered reasonable protocols
uh Pastor Hamilton decided to hold a
drive-in church service this was right
at the beginning of all of this and uh
and and yet 20 police cars showed up at
Pastor Hamilton's church that means 20
police officers were not out uh
arresting rapists and murderers no they
were finding every person who attended
the outdoor Drive-In church service
$500 including Pastor Hamilton so that's
the kind of abuse that uh that pastors
faced thank
you
this any other questions
represent any similar in in New
you I'm sorry rip in Horan I didn't if
you asked me a question I didn't hear it
were there any were there any similar
incidents in New Hampshire um I mean I I
can look up the King James Bible
incident I don't know how many people
were there 20 police cars may have been
it may have been reasonable unreasonable
depending on the size of the crowd and
um the size of the place where they were
assembling but I mean we had uh almost
that many we had probably about we had
like a number of police officers
probably that many just for our driving
just for our house session um including
the drive-in session that we ourselves
had in my town of dur if you're
comfortable sending 20 police officers
to to to to a
church I I don't know what to say about
that but in the state of New Hampshire I
am not a aware of any uh pastors that
were find anything because our governor
uh responded very quickly after uh a lot
of this started making national news and
we went from having to be completely
shut down to well at least we could open
and have 10 people in service so the
governor responded rather quickly before
he could be
sued thank you follow up you probably
followup so one last okay so that okay I
can't speak to the government state of
mind you
do you favor uh treating um religious
organizations and then perhaps
non-religious organizations that wish to
have meetings um uh differently in the
law or do you think maybe we should prer
modifying it to bring in a wider range
of organizations so well if I'm reading
the First Amendment of the US
Constitution the uh freedom of religion
is expressly stated and so there it's
not like we have to carve out anything
special for Religious Freedom it's
already there now as far as any uh other
uh philanthropic organization or
philosophical organization if you get
yourself declared a religion then you
would fall under that atheists have been
determined to be uh be a religion as
well so atheists can get together under
the religious freedom so it's a it's a
all for one if it's a religion uh but
the uh it's it's already carved out
that's why I said that this V this bill
is actually should not even be necessary
but it actually is necessary because
government keeps uh Towing the line or
overstepping it thank you are there any
other questions for representive
G seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you very
huitt good morning Mr chairman can you
hear me we can I thank you thank you
I'll just respond to a few of the points
that have been made already and then
I'll take any legal questions um I guess
I'll respond first to representative
Horan's last point about um there not
being any fines uh of churches in New
Hampshire that's true there have been no
fines um I think this is first and
foremost a preventative measure um in
light of what we've seen in other states
it's appropriate for the legislature to
think ahead about problems that might
arise in the future just based on what
we observe and and try to fix those
problems before they come up I will say
that Governor sununu's executive orders
did initially have Provisions um which
did treat churches more restrictively
than other similarly situated kinds of
entities um but fortunately before those
Provisions could be applied to anyone or
enforced uh it was brought to the
governor's attention that those
Provisions were likely unconstitutional
um and the governor and his office
recognized that and removed those
Provisions so it is just something of a
natural tendency of state governments um
especially in in a state like New
Hampshire which is more secular to just
not deem churches to be particularly
important and that's an important reason
to have a protection like this in in
State Statute um the next Governor might
not be as Forward Thinking um or as
benevolent as as governor cunu was far
as this has come up a couple times the
idea of special protections for religion
and not other groups I think that both
the Federal Constitution and our state
constitution make that value judgment
that religion warrants special
protections there's special free
exercise Clauses in both um there's not
special protections for labor
organizations or other kinds of groups
um because of the particular importance
of the topic of religion and we see this
already in existing law in in the
Supreme Court case Hosanna Tabor for
example which was 2012 the US Supreme
Court held there's a ministerial
exception the government flat out can
never tell churches um what ministers to
hire and fire that's just not true of
other kinds of organizations um so this
statute I think just reflects that value
judgment and you could say this really
about any constitutional um right you
know abortion is a constitutional right
in the US other kinds of medical
procedures aren't um the Supreme Court's
decided our our constitution makes that
value judge and my obviously I might
have some objections to the result but
not to the idea of some things being
warranting special
cons um as far as representative
Alexander's question about the idea of
[Music]
yeah sure well I'll just I'll point to
the the New Hampshire Supreme Court's
case um in the back decision um which
you can easily pull up online on on page
21 of that decision the court said there
the compelling State interest balancing
test has proven to be a workable
standard in free exercise cases so I
just don't think there's any evidence
and I think this is true at the national
level as well that this is actually
going to lead to all kinds of Chaos um
or nullifying of ordinary laws the US
Supreme Court also addressed this issue
in the sherbet decision in the 60s and
it said we don't see any evidence this
kind of mingering or deceit is going to
be a real problem and if there were some
evidence it probably wouldn't be
sufficient to
justify imposing on free exercise of
religion so for those reasons I think
that it's important to have some special
protections for places of worship and in
a time of emergency especially but also
generally thank thank you Mr are there
he seeing none thanks for your testimony
today thank
there
oh good day and thank you for uh for
hearing me thank you Mr chair and the
committee members I appreciate you
taking the time to uh to hear us my name
is Scott Mitchell I'm the pastor the
senior pastor at the New Hampton
Community Church in New Hampton New
Hampshire I really do urge you to
support this bill because churches have
a very significant part in our
communities uh even in New Hampshire
where it may be a small uh small parts
in our small towns it really does
provide a large and significant impact
in our community unities through this uh
pandemic that we've been in we have been
actively caring for people in our
community uh people in our our area have
been doing grocery shopping they've been
providing meals they've done assistance
for groceries as in financial assistance
uh we've been doing Wellness calls
helping with heating supplies and other
ways uh giving people rides to hospital
when that was appropriate or I should
say to doctor's appointments when that
was appropriate and uh and
safe and I really believe that we can be
trusted to safeguard the health and of
the people in our congregation and the
surrounding communities uh churches
really are essential for the emotional
and spiritual health of our communities
and it is very important that we uphold
this and allow the government to give
guidelines on Gathering but allow
churches to make the decision uh and and
be wise and focus on the health of our
people but it is essential uh for
churches to be able to regulate uh and
know when we can gather and not be
regulated by the government so I
appreciate your time and the opportunity
to speak before you and I'm happy to
take any questions you might happen to
have for me thank you Reverend Mitchells
thank you for staying within your time
are there any questions for Reverend
Mitchell seeing none thank you very
Barnes again all the people who were
remaining to speak or signed up
support can you hear me okay you can
great thank you so much as you said my
name is John Barnes I'm the pastor of
the state line Baptist Church in
Portsmith New Hampshire and my wife and
I live in pelum we've lived there for
seven years and actually almost eight
years we started the church State Line
Baptist Church is a church plant in
Portsmith we tell the whole story
especially since I have two minutes but
um I want to reference an email that I
sent to the um to Governor sununu last
May and to the uh reopen committee and
such in reference to the church just
kind of echoing what this pastor just
said a moment ago but um I liken the
church you know probably many of us even
in this committee have and if you don't
that's fine but many of us have some
form of a church relationship and and I
like to liken the church to many
different things from a spiritual
perspective a spiritual
hospital um but I my I think the best
way and the email says this a little bit
so I don't want to just be redundant but
I really liken the church to a
family you know and I can't help but
think uh even just uh two days ago on
Wednesday I had the privilege to
officiate the funeral at um military
cemetery there in conquer for a
93-year-old World War II veteran uh
Lynwood Lesley served our country
an amazing man who really um I've only
known personally for the last maybe six
to eight months but the door opened
because about a year and a half ago I
had the privilege to start doing
services on Tuesday nights church
services on Tuesday nights at Maple
Suites which is a retirement community
in Dover just about 20 minutes from our
church and and um I say that partly
because of just thinking of the the many
facets of the church and the privilege
to Ser serve and love the people in our
communities as this previous Pastor just
said and um and again if it's not
obviously I realize it's not the
immediate family but it's an extended
family and I just the privilege to
minister to the lesle family and then um
and then the folks at Maple Suites and
we respected of course the four to five
months that we were uh we needed to wait
to be able to be in there and maple
Suites but um I Echo the sentiment
wholeheartedly uh the essentiality of
the church and I want to thank you for
giving me two minutes to share just a
little bit of my heart and thank you for
uh thank you for listening to all these
uh reports and supported this Bill thank
you are there any questions for Reverend
bar yes uh representative mlan thank you
Mr chair um I'll be brief one of the
things has always interested me is
because I'm a Catholic and so there were
rules around our church closing um I saw
the Home Depot stay open and I saw the
grocery stores stay open but we did see
and I I felt the churches were essential
in your Communications back and forth
with the governor and these various
committees did did he give you any
communication as to why there were
restrictions or limits on on your
congregation did he give any additional
re
behind that is that
communication no sir no
sir thank you yes sir any other
questions see none thank you again for
your testimony today thank you for the
privilege yeah I'm just going to ask
everybody everybody who is going to
remain to speak is speaking in support
so if you could just be we we're really
short on time if you could just be
succinct and if you have anything
additional to add that would really be
Carlson good morning good morning my
name is David Carlson I thank you for
the opportunity to speak in support of
this bill I the pastor of Gospel Baptist
Church right in downtown Manchester uh
one half a block off of Elm Street right
behind the Red AR restaurant I've been
the pastor here for 29 years and I'm
supporting the regular scheduled worship
and church services in the event of such
an emergency which if 1800 and something
was the last time hopefully we got it
over with for another 200 years that'd
be good um we work with many people off
the street and many of them I haven't
seen in a year they have spiritual needs
they have emotional needs their family
situations are impacted we' made some
adjustments which have been very helpful
we've gone to Facebook live and we did
have to have 10 people and then you know
little bit bigger amount now half of our
occupancy and so we've done social
distancing uh separated the pews U taped
off marks on the floor people wear masks
uh they have more gloves and you know
different things I work extensively with
the incarcerated those who have gotten
out of jail those who've gotten out of
prison and we are probably averaging 20
to 30 a week here at church uh from from
that type of background and I was
listening to I think a news article this
morning on the radio they were talking
about the reism r and that's something
that we always want to eliminate people
going back I think church is really
important with that because it connects
people with the community with a pastor
with faith and we've seen so much growth
in this area and we've seen that just
drop off in a major way but people turn
to church they turn turn to religion the
Bible assembling with each other for
support and encouragement we should be
allowed to do this safely at least as
safe as going to a lumber yard or
grocery store car you could just wind up
you okay any questions for R
Carlson seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
carahan
yes can you hear me you can uh well I
thank you Mr chairman committee members
uh I'm Reverend Edward Carnahan pastor
of Portsmith Believers Church and I
support HB
542 I believe churches are essential at
any time but especially during a time of
Crisis uh one of the things that I want
to make in the few minutes that I have
here is uh why churches are essential
this is never a question that's asked
with Walmart or Home Depot because it's
obvious why they're essential but for
churches during a time of Crisis three
three things always happen in society
during a time of Crisis um fear panic
and distrust of the government when left
unchecked all three can increase the
severity of the crisis and hinder the
government's role in solving the problem
meeting people face to face brings a
sense of Peace normality and inclusion
which will calm an individual and
relieve stress I'll conclude by saying
in 1933 during his inaugural address
Franklin rosev who at the time was
facing one of the greatest threats to
this country in the world said we have
nothing to fear but fear itself he
recognized that fear in people stops the
progress necessary to overcome the
crisis the church is by far the most
qualified organization in existence to
deal with this effectively and this is
why I deem church is essential thank
you thank you for your brief testimony
appreciate it any
questions seeing none again thank you
corham can you hear me we can hear you
I'll keep it brief as well um my name is
Justin Coram I Just Want to Thank You Mr
chair and members of the committee uh I
am in support of House Bill 542 and I'm
I'm not going to uh you know most of the
same reasons have already been mentioned
you know i' I've seen the increase um in
anxiety depression
hopelessness uh particularly in the
young people that I am working with um
in in my community and and when things
shut down um how important connection is
for them and and they were separated
from not only friends but separated from
worshiping God together as a community
and and really didn't have a spiritual a
place to be spiritually encouraged or
emotionally supported and and I think
there's been so much emotional trauma
throughout um this year and I'm sure
each of us have experienced it in one
way or another throughout um 2020 and
even to today and so I think for a lot
of our church members it's just so
important to be able to gather together
and to be encouraged and really
empowered to face the next day with
purpose and I mean for us Church
community faith is what fills us with
purpose it gives us a a a re to live um
and so you know it reminds people that
they're loved by God they're loved by
the people in their community and uh
they're here for a reason and that they
have a purpose and obviously like
mentioned before grocery stores gas
stations clothing stores nobody's
arguing that all of these places
hospitals they're they're very much
Essential but just to express how we
feel um the spiritual and mental
well-being that churches provide people
is just as essential uh if not more in
in my opinion as as these other
essential Services um so I just want to
thank you for your time God bless you
thank you any questions Mr
Corp see them thank you again for
testifying
you're there raise your
hand don't see
him
Ed
pastor
okay Pastor Ed uh thank you very much um
members of the committee I not going to
be labor I'm Pastor Ed hary of Trinity
Lutheran Church in Kean New Hampshire
God bless you today as his ordained
servants um and Servants of the people
uh I I won't belabor anything else um
that my brothers have said uh colleagues
before and after uh I'm just going to
just uh I forwarded you my a statement
um and you have that before you uh but
uh I will just quote um uh the preacher
uh the son of David um in Ecclesiastes 4
when he says two are better than one or
if they fall one will lift up his fellow
but woe to him who is alone when he
falls and has not another to lift him up
a court of three strands is not quickly
broken and uh that speaks to what
everyone else has said and so I will
defer uh to them uh as I can add nothing
else to what they have said thank you
for your time thank you so much are
there any
questions see none thank you for your
testimony thank you for being brief we
Moore if you're there if you could raise
go
good morning can you hear me you can
very good uh good morning uh Mr chair
and the members of the committee again
thank you for uh for H holding this
meeting so we could speak to this uh
issue my name is raore I'm senior pastor
of the church at the intersection in
marac I've also sent you an email with
these statements so uh rather than
reiterate what everybody's already said
I agree to uh to these other pastors
other comments have been made um the
Constitution it of this um also but the
the the history of New England and the
church in New England has been powerful
the biggest colleges up here the most
esteemed universities they were started
by people who were religious and the
church was core to that uh and Church of
course can be without Sunday morning or
it can it be that's that's the big
question and it really can't be I've
heard a couple of the other pastors
mention that young children young people
and seniors were affected by this and
indeed that was the case in our church
and we've noticed in the last few weeks
being able to breathe a little more
obviously over last year trying to be
safe trying to be prudent trying to be
uh within State protocol we did all that
but we've been able to open up a little
more here lately and and people are
hungry for the fellowship and the
communication the interaction uh so
again I can I can go with the other
pastors and tell you that people need
this uh it does contribute to the
community and um I would say this to an
ending Home Depot and Walmart went
around 200 years ago when the
universities were being started in towns
are being established the church was and
it assisted in that and continues today
so I think it's a very important part of
the culture of linin and I would just
say that and encourage you again to
support HB 542 I thank you for your time
and I appreciate your service thank you
very much your testimon is appreciated
and are there any
questions see none thank you very much
Sullivan
you're there raise your hand so we can
see
PTZ can you hear me now you can good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Nate PTZ I'm the
pastor of Harvest Bible Church in gilmon
Iron Works I appreciate the opportunity
to show support for HP 542 the framers
of our constitution understood that
people of Faith are bound by conscience
to fulfill the mandates of their
religion and while there is a great
diversity of religious conviction in New
Hampshire these convictions reside at
the very core of who we are as people in
other words the corporate religious
gathering is essential no different in
importance than purchasing food
receiving medical care or engaging in
gainful employment if the covid-19
crisis has taught us anything it's that
the mental emotional and spiritual needs
of a person are just as essential as
their physical needs furthermore our
church and other Christian churches like
us are commanded to assemble ourselves
together corporately something we cannot
Faithfully observe online we are called
to gather together not leaving anybody
out or limiting their access through
capacity restriction s and while
together we are called by God to cor
corporate prayer singing observing
sacramental ordinances and fellowship
without these elements present and
active we're disobeying the dictates of
our conscience as we would be defying
God we regularly engage in practices
designed to protect our church from all
forms of harm we do this not because the
government directs us to but because we
exercise discernment and compassion
toward one another by upholding HP 542
and our religious freedom together for
peaceful worship we are both honoring
and obeying God which is essential for
us as well as honoring our obligations
to submit ourselves to the government
thank you thank you and represent mlan
did you have a question yes with your
Indulgence Mr chair so uh thank you and
thanks for taking my question so we've
heard a lot of folks in government go
out of their way to recognize healthcare
workers recognize grocery store workers
recognize all these U essential uh areas
and work with them to make sure that
they're able to stay open and in your
experience in your dealing with the
folks in government has it been your
experience that you've been treated in
the same way with that same level of
recognition and that same level of work
to get you opened up in the way that
these other sectors were opened
up thank you for the question I
appreciate the opportunity to respond uh
I was on a conference call with several
other pastors with Senator Bob GAA he
was wonderful to work with he was an
advocate for us uh but we were uh the
general experience that we had was that
it was very very slow and uh and very
very sluggish uh to get us open we were
under the impression we would be shut
down for maybe two to four weeks just
like the pandemic in 1918 we ended up
our church stayed closed for 11 weeks
and we pushed hard but we want to
observe our subordinates to the
government and so we worked hard to be
patient but uh we did not feel like we
were receiving the same level of of
importance or uh even watching the
briefings online little to no mention of
relig religious organizations and so we
did not in my a personal opinion uh
you thank you are there any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
saw thank you for your time and service
to our country and our state I am the
pastor of lifee Church in Dar New
Hampshire I've been Pastor there for 21
years it's been one of the greatest
honors to serve our community I just
have to say that uh serving our
community for all these years during
many of the crisis we've had with
snowstorms even the ice storm in
2008 we have been able to provide
effectively for the spiritual physical
emotional and mental needs of the
people and it
has made for a better nit Community
we've hosted many blog parties where we
give everything for free and I believe
the church like I tell our people it's
like a a Lifeboat in the middle of
Titanic emergencies we want to be there
when there's needs when people are
drowning in hopelessness in fear in
distress they need someone to stand with
them the church is ready to do that
history attests to that in the second
and third Century in the plagues of
antonine in Cyprus many of the
Christians went out there to help their
communities and I think we will be a
better and stronger state for that and I
appreciate you listening so I fully
support this bill and I hope that we can
continue to strengthen our communities
and make them healthy by serving as
Christ served us thank you so much thank
you for your testimony and are there any
questions
Arkansas seeing none again thank you
there are six more people who have
registered to sign sign up I I hope you
can be brief in your testimony and if
you have something new to add that would
there he has to
unmute don't see him on the screen he's
middle he has an old Zoom so he have to
unmute hello are you there yes sorry
about that um so my name is Paul sag I'm
pastor of the Light of the World Church
in Milford New Hampshire the South
heagan Valley I think I do have
something new to add to the conversation
though I agree with my fellow pastors um
we're in um the Sagan Valley in Southern
Southern New Hampshire where um where we
where we serve as a faith community um
as part of the fabric of our community
not independently the faith community in
saan belly has a history of standing
with our community part Partners not as
a standalone resource um we view each
other as co-laborers collaborators and
we actually like each other and we meet
each other weekly on Zoom meetings and
trainings um working for the same goal
as a healthy Community um when covid hit
in in last year a year ago we were the
faith community were already in a
position to work alongside our community
agencies and leaders schools Boys and
Girls Club Nami bridg Milford welfare
share and provide food and other
essential basic resources for the poor
and needy especially the elderly our
faith community provided a strong
volunteer basis um many of whom had
attended and received trainings so that
they could be more effective in their
communities our own church offered a
recovery coach training last year where
five members of our church are now
available to serve productively in
recovery centers um which the faith
community operates in the heagan Valley
we know that in these emergencies uh
needs of the EM of the recovery
Community sore our faith community was
intentional about becoming a Good
Samaritan which is the essential call of
the church it called it's called the
Great Commission meeting the needs of
the underserved is certainly good news
years ago we formed a multi-church
Outreach team which organizes our
network of churches to respond when
needs suddenly arise like an emergency
like a pandemic we plan to be ready to
serve because we were intentional about
building partners and networks with
proven success so my question is simply
this why why
would could you could you finish up
your I guess I could finish just asking
the question is why would you want to
undercut the the health of our
communities by eliminating the faith
community from precip from participating
in this particular way thank you very
much we are
essential any questions for Reverend
s n thank you for your testimony today
testerman yes you may have to unmute
all
right okay um ladies and gentlemen I'm
Patrick testerman I'm my uh pastor and
uh in Louden New Hampshire I'm also a
retired military combat veteran and have
since my uh retirement served as a New
Hampshire law enforcement officer taught
constitutional application at the
primary uh high school and University
levels as worshiper of Jesus Christ uh
called to take up my cross daily and
also sent into this world on deadly
serious about both my faith and my
Constitution uh when any of the branches
of uh government fail to execute their
duties overstep their authori
responsibility the other branches to
hold them accountable if necessary to
take appropriate steps within their own
authority to prevent repetition of these
abuses I want to be clear I believe
Governor cunu has done an extraordinary
job in extraordinary circumstances we
look at other leaders across our nation
and the world we can see a wide range of
actions from Reckless indifference
fearful idity and outright
authoritarianism uh within or among
those leaders Governor Cudo was on the
top constantly balancing State interests
and constitutional rights risks and
benefits information and the unknown uh
I was privileged to be a member of his
task force and leader a smaller working
group that helped formulate guidance for
reopening houses of worship last year I
found him in his office in most cases to
be very reasonable and eager to move
that process forward and I thank him for
that yet mistakes were made overreach
has occurred and at two particular time
times I joined with other pastors uh to
call out those abuses and eventually end
up in a precipitous uh conflict uh
details of that I will send on with my
extended remarks uh though I disagreed
with the governor in these cases I did
not call into question his Integrity
character efforts or overall performance
however I do believe that it's time for
the governor and his legislature to take
Tes take action to over to prevent
future oversteps of authority uh when
passed by the court and Senate and
signed by the governor this will begin
the corrective action it will help
secure vital freedom to worship as
guaranteed by the First Amendment of the
United States Constitution in part one
Article 5 the New Hampshire
Constitution regardless of the distaste
for that of Representative Oregan
evidently I ask for your rep uh your
support of this
Bill thank you for your testimony you
repr Horan do you have a
question you need to
unmute called me up by name I'm not sure
whether whether I guess uh probably
probably violation the rules so that's
uh actually I had more friendly question
which was uh it's a familiar name around
the state house so you related to
representative testan and then also
Teran test and his wife a former
governor
candidate I am I I don't think that's an
appropriate question represent okay
thank you I don't think anyway I mean
yes I I just want to say I'm I'm still
like I'm listening to to the debate and
I um I'm I'm allowed to think whatever I
think and um so I probably uh didn't
feel good to have somebody uh you know
puning my puning my motives it's you
know as I'm gonna reach a decision about
this bill when it when we have the exact
session and that's uh that's that's what
I was sent here to do so that's what I'm
doing so um May I respond actually no uh
are there any other questions for Mr
Reverend
Tes thank thank you thank you for your
Testament okay the next person to
Wagner hello there can you hear me
we can hey thank you for your time uh I
know the pastors have said many things
that I I agree with so uh the value that
I could add yes while I am a First
Amendment guy and uh when in doubt
follow the first amendment I feel like
you uh may need to hear uh from one of
us stating or speaking to your possible
fear that we're not big boys and girls
that uh we might just go off half cocked
because of a religious Pursuit and and
put our folks in danger um you know we
love these people uh if they are to pass
away from a decision we're the ones who
are going to bury them and you know
perform their funerals and cry with the
families right we love our community
we're we're taking calculated risks to
uh assist them in their time of need and
we're not interested in just declaring
our rights I mean we just want to
continue doing what we've always done
and be a blessing to the community and
and the value that we had you know the
the place where the state really needs
us during the lockdowns we've seen so
many cases of of anxiety physical abuse
substance abuse depression uh we've seen
some suicides we've encountered many
single parents struggling to take care
of their children who are now at being
schooled at home while trying to figure
out how to work their jobs or maybe not
have jobs unemployment had broken down
in many cases families were hungry
didn't know how to find uh clothing food
it just finances were a mess and and the
church is jumping into those messes and
assisting and you know if if if the
church were to just close down and I'm
not only talking about Sunday mornings
but all of the involvement that they do
within the communities within
house-to-house Ministry within uh large
public Gatherings or small private
Gatherings you know we're gonna use
wisdom but man you'd miss us if we were
gone thank you thank you for your
testimonies thank you for staying within
questions van W seeing none thank you
again there's three more witnesses the
next one is
Tim
viralon good
morning this is Tim uh I'm the senior
pastor at Real Life Church in Lone New
Hampshire and uh thank you for on a
moment of levity thank you for taking a
name um I am so thankful for the job
that you all do and a group of local
area pastors and I pray for you and your
colleagues very regularly um and I'd
like to like my other colleagues urge
you to support House Bill
542 uh because as been stated so well by
many others already we not only provide
spiritual services to our communities in
The Lakes Region but practical Services
as well back in March we had just
completed our uh the first phase of our
building project to get into our new
building in Downtown lone
and had one service and then shut down
uh and so many people from our
congregation we have not seen since last
March we've been in communication with
them uh as many pastors have have done
so as well but there are a lot of people
that we serve not just in a spiritual
capacity but as other pastors have said
in a needs-based capacity and and if we
were to uh just simply keep the doors
closed we would figure out a way to make
it work um a friend of mine commented
said just like that we be all became
telea evangelists uh halfway jokingly
and so we have done our best to turn on
a dime but I want to urge you to support
this build just because there are uh
many needs that we provide uh the
answers to and uh again like I said
thank you for your time thank you for
how you serve us and I really appreciate
this time to share this uh request to
you God bless you have a great day thank
you for your testimony thank you for
staying within your time any
[Music]
questions seeing none thank you very
we don't see Malcolm
warl good morning um my name is Matthew
warl I'm pastor of Grace Christian
Fellowship in Winchester New Hampshire
and I am been patiently waiting to be
able to just tell you of my support of
HP um HB
542 we had closed our church for two and
a half months last spring and witnessed
much distress among our congregation and
even our community it was sad to see
depression anxiety and a general sense
of fear overtake many in our
congregation I believe the church is
essential is an essential entity that
many in our society look to for Comfort
Direction and compassion during
stressful times I.E one thing was why we
were shut down is the number of funerals
I had to turn away and I had to to talk
with those families and and uh uh try to
explain to them why as a church we can't
meet this need of their family because
the state has closed us down uh that was
a really sad and very very difficult
time for myself and I'm sure other
pastors had the same uh sameeh stressful
difficulties when church was closed down
those people lost a sense of support
that that they look towards you know
when it comes to funerals and and uh um
uh our bread uh food Ministry we had to
shut down these are things that are
essential uh not just spiritually but
practical uh essential needs for uh
families in our community uh we had to
close down yet big box stores were
allowed to stay open other stores were
allowed to stay open liquor stores were
allowed to stay open but we had to close
down we're well we are well aware of how
to care for our community and
congregation and we can be trusted to
install the necessary guidelines to keep
our community and congregation safe
during these times we are well able to
govern ourselves the scripture is clear
that we are not to forsake the
assembling of ourselves together and we
have the privilege and responsibility to
govern ourselves and never be fully
closed down uh I thank you for giving me
the honor of uh talking to you and
giving you my my thoughts um
the church is essential in our
communities and that has been very clear
uh during this time that time that
period of time that we had to be shut
down okay thank you for your testimony
today are there any questions Rend
War seeing none again thank you that
concludes the list of people who
pre-registered to uh testify here today
is there anyone else who feels compelled
to
testify
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on House Bill
542 we'll be executing on that next
Wednesday next hearing is on uh we are
way behind this morning and know
so I'm not going to take a break if
people need to if members of the
committee need to take a break and leave
for short periods of time that's fine it
certainly to be understood but I don't
think I can take take a break at this
point the next bill to be heard is House
Bill
and there are only two people who are
signed up to testify on
it one of whom is the prime sponsor
representative Dolan this is a bill
relative to electronic
notice and I note that there were 13
people who signed up in support and no
one signed up in opposition and
representative Dolan if you're available
bill and I don't see representative
Dolan
there m would you like to introduce the
B yes thank you Mr chair
um the record uh my name is
representative mlan representing
Hillsboro District 44 and I would like
to uh introduce House Bill uh
testimony also signing having signed up
to speak was natch Grace and is he
available
hello uh chairman can you hear me you
can my name is n Grace I am with the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association we are in support of HB 379
it's actually a policy bill for us it is
a rather lengthy bill that enacts a very
simple change it allows municipalities
to provide electronic notice via posting
on on their website in lie of newspaper
notice for certain
hearings it follows last year's adoption
of HB 1129 which allowed a planning
board to post notice on proposed zoning
ordinances on the website instead of in
newspaper uh the Bill's rather lengthy
because there are dozens of sections of
the rsas where newspaper notice is
required for public
hearings uh in theory the easiest
approach would probably be to do a
blanket Amendment but we had to Iden
ified two problems with that first uh
there are a few situations where we
weren't we didn't think that electronic
notice would be appropriate at this time
and so Universal rule wouldn't work
because you'd have to have exceptions
and secondly uh in most cases the uh
notice requirements for the individual
statutes also specify that there must be
publication in the newspaper so someone
would have to be very familiar with the
statutes and know that there was another
place where there was a substitute that
said you could post on the website so in
order to make it easier for everyone
unfortunately the bill has to be
somewhat lengthy uh to update all of the
statutes
individually that's my uh concise
summary I did submit written testimony
that is uh to that same effect that I'm
happy to take any questions on the bill
representative
syvia thank you Mr chairman I'll be
brief and thank you for taking my
question um one of the ones that I
notice is not there is uh County
delegation noce um it was left out for a
particular reason uh it was not uh we
don't represent counties so we would not
have uh proposed any sort of changes to
those um I'll note that not all
newspaper um notice requirements are
listed um this is just a list of a large
number of them um
unfortunately in going through the
statutes it's so cumbersome that we
thought that to make it reasonable for
the Comm committee to act on um limiting
the list to probably the most important
ones this year and then proposing
another bill next next session uh Etc
until we till we get them all down uh
seemed more
appropriate thank you representative
mlan thank you Mr chair just super quick
um is the driver behind this uh more on
the cost side or more that you're
finding it's a more effective way to
reach people just trying to understand
the the driver
behind really it's a it's a very
effective way of of reaching people um
as I'm sure all of you know many of your
communities are using um not only the
websites uh for their municipalities but
they often have linked social media
accounts that push out updates to um
board and chair meetings so a lot of
people are getting their news that way
um but of course there is a cost Factor
as well um unfortunately a large number
of smaller newspapers throughout our
State have closed um meaning that the
newspapers of General circulation are
larger ones like the union leader and
ads in those those cost more um so there
will be some cost savings but I I
wouldn't know exact numbers and that
would depend on the individual Community
I
imagine representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for take my question Mr Grace um how
does this bill intersect with RS
91a the right to no
bill right so RSA
9182 uh requires uh posting in two
public places for any notice of a
meeting uh one of those can be a the
municipality's website and that's
actually um that was actually an
amendment that occur I believe in 2018
or
2019 um how this would play out is that
obviously you'd have to have two public
places and if there's also a newspaper
requirement you'd have to find two
separate public places so you'd have you
know the town hall and the library the
town hall and and the post office two
physical locations plus the website for
the municipality and I do want to be
clear um that there is a provision in
the law already that the municipality's
website has to be a real website it
can't be you know the the community's
Facebook page it has to be someplace
that's accessible to everyone who goes
on the
internet thank you repres Morgan uh yes
thank you very much Mr chair uh thank
you very much Mr Grace um and I I I
think we do need to update the law like
I see for example we talk about
newspaper Statewide circulation we
really only have one and even the union
leader probably not on the news stands
everywhere in the state but my main
question is with the newspaper first of
all at least in theory everybody gets it
every copy of the newspaper is the same
so like the ad is the same and also it's
uh it's permanent the union leader is
even you know archived online and on
microfilm which actually publisher
alluded to an unrelated Bill the other
day so how do we do the electronic
notice in such a way that U it's uh that
it's definitely the same for everybody
that an agreed person can't argue that
what there people different people are
getting different version of notice and
how do we sure that it's it's it's
permanent thank you so as far as it
being the same for everyone um it would
have to be uh you know it would be
on the the municipality's web page and
so on the front page when you go to you
know conquer. goov or or manchester.
goov or whatever your website is for
your municipality um if you are posting
notices on your front page you should
have a either the notice itself or a
link to direct people to where the
calendar is um and then the calendar is
going to be the same no matter how
you're visiting that uh I'm not aware of
any current uh requirement that notices
be preserved um that would be under RSA
33 hyphen a colon 3 hyphen a um which is
the municipal records uh retention
statute uh I
don't believe that there's a requirement
that notices of meetings are archived uh
if that's something the committee wishes
to uh require then uh it it could do
so oh thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
house
see no other hands and we'll close the
379 move on House Bill open the hearing
on House Bill 597 FN relative to the
expectation of
privacy know that there are eight people
who have signed up to speak on this
primary speaker is rep uh the primary SP
excuse me is representative Earth
and we'll call upon representative F to
T go ahead
representative thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the committee I'm
Representative Keith F Hills Ro District
2 represent the towns of Daring and wear
sponsor of HB 597 and I'm speaking in
support of that
bill HB 597 protects an individual's
informational privacy from government
intrusion it bars state and local
governments from accessing an
individual's personal information which
he or she has provided to
non-governmental third parties in 2018
New Hampshire citizens
passed the right to privacy amendment to
our constitution with 81% voting in
favor this amendment States quote an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent end quote hb5 97
continues the process of defining this
right in statute this is the the same
bill that passed the house last year it
passed out of committee 14 to5 and
passed the house on a Voice vote the
constraints of covid prevented the
Senate from considering it last year and
it was laid on the
table the bill clearly defines what
constitutes personal information as it
relates to this
bill it states the expectation of
privacy that we have as it relates to
our personal information that we give to
companies we interact with in our daily
lives it provides no government employee
elected official or government
contractor shall
acquire collect retain or use personal
information HB
597 includes clear exceptions for
emergencies warrants and
subpoenas information required by law or
information that the individual agrees
need not be subject to this
privacy as The Honorable Sandra ke wrote
year quote two years ago the citizens
voted overwhelmingly for a
constitutional amendment to protect
their
privacy this bill is a modest attempt to
put some statutes in place to start the
process it does not cover everything and
future legislators will certainly find
more areas to
cover it does require warrants for
governmental bodies before they Snoop
however it does allow for an emergency
situation your personal information
should remain private to the extent
possible end
quote the committee received a letter
from the government Affairs coordinator
of New Hampshire regarding the effective
date of HB
597 and I defer to the judge judement of
the committee on this testifying at some
point after me is The Honorable Neil
Kirk who authored the original bill that
has been resubmitted this year he is
able to address the exceptions and
compatibility with existing laws in
Greater detail in the interest of your
time it might be best to address your
questions to him as he can provide more
in-depth
responses thank you for your time and if
you do have questions for me I will try
to address them okay and there any
Earth seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Mr
chair next speaker will be uh former
okay good morning Mr chairman good
morning
uh it's good to see you uh good morning
to you and to members of the committee
for the record I'm Neil Kirk I was a
former representative and I now live as
I have formerly in wear um I support
this bill I think it's a very important
first step in implementing the
Constitutional privacy amendment that
was recently passed by over 80% of the
state's voters this bill does two things
it establishes right of privacy in
personal information that's in the hands
of third parties
non-government uh organizations I'll
talk to that in a minute and it also uh
says that the legislature not government
agencies shall determine whether or not
informational databases are created in
the
future those are very two very important
but very different
things
um as you know as we go through life we
deal with all sorts of other agen genes
internet service providers credit card
companies Banks telephone
companies um social network
organizations and we give them all sorts
of informations to information about
ourselves to enroll our names or
addresses sometimes Social Security
numbers um biometric identifiers all
sorts of things at the
moment these are not protected so that
if uh a state agency or individual
wishes to get this information and the
private organization is willing to
provide it that person can get that
information without a subpoena or
without a warrant if the agency the
organization the private organization
won't Supply the information uh the
state official could get it um uh today
um by going and getting a subpoena or a
warrant but the point is he now can or
she can now get it uh just simply by
asking for it this bill would say no if
you want personal information about an
individual and that personal information
is held in private hands and you're a
government official uh then you either
have to get a warrant or a subpoena or
it has to be an emergency or some other
exception that's written into the
bill um I think that's what people
expect that their government will not go
about collecting this personal
information about them uh unless the
legislature is authorized it or unless
they get a Judicial warrant or
subpoena um the second part of the bill
is equally important right now various
agencies can create databases of
personal information obtained
legitimately and use it for whatever
purposes they wish this bill says no
that's a legislative decision um and
there are some exceptions to this of
course but it's a legislative decision
the legislature will determine what
informational
databases the state is going to create
and state agencies will have to
administer um
that's the essence of the bill as
representative Earth said this was
passed by the house last year and got
hung up in the Senate due to covid
issues uh I hope the committee will see
the wisdom of its prior actions and um
vote the bill ought to pass thank you Mr
chairman I'd be pleased to answer any
questions that members may have thank
Smith thank you very much Mr uh chairman
um uh representative Kirk um we've had a
lot of testimony come in and I wonder if
you could if the chair would permit me
to ask just uh three questions the first
is um the municipal Association claims
that this bill's strict prohibition
would inhibit the investigation of
criminal offenses could you comment on
that uh yes it doesn't um it would
simply require that the law enforcement
agency obtain a subpoena or a warrant in
order to get this information it would
prevent them from getting it as they can
now from simply
asking thank you may I follow up Mr
chair May thank you um uh the New
Hampshire Municipal Association says
that ambiguous language and strict
liability requirement could result in
municipalities facing sign ific
penalties for unknowing or unintentional
violations could you comment on that um
first of all I I think I have more faith
than Mr Johnston in Municipal officials
um in the sense that they are quite
careful and cautious and follow the
rules um but beyond that um the penalty
here is for violating a provision of
this and that requires intent
because it's a criminal act so they have
to do something intentionally I don't
think there would be a penalty if
inadvertence um was the reasons reason
for their Action Now inadvertence
doesn't mean carelessness and sloppiness
it means the inability they just didn't
know they read the law and they just
didn't understand it and didn't
know and if I could have just one more
this would be my last Mr chair that be
fine representative Smith thank you Mr
chair um the banking uh Department says
that um the language on page two line 17
appears to be intended to allow state
agencies to do their jobs but this
language would not authorize the
department to obtain information in
examination unless it was respected
requested with respect to a particular
individual so that the uh Amendment uh
or this bill would not permit uh the
banking uh Department to perform its
statutory
duties in examinations of financial
institutions that might be a random
examination could you comment on that
yes I thought that those issues in
particular had been addressed in one or
both of paragraph 507 H colon
2B and 2 c i I'm sorry I can't give you
the line numbers because the copy of the
bill that's available on the internet
does not have line numbers on it B says
subparagraph a that's the paragraph that
says um there's a right to privacy and
it it requires a warrant says
subparagraph a shall not
apply
um to Affinity type programs which is
not the issue here but C2 uh sorry B
says I I apologize Mr chairman I read
the wrong section B says subparagraph a
shall not apply to personal information
authorized no wait a second I I
apologize I'm reading the wrong section
here it's Roman
4 507 H2 Roman 4 this chapter shall not
apply to personal information required
collected retained or used by any state
regulatory agency that's the banking
Department with respect to a particular
individual when such acquisition
collection retention or use is with the
within the agency's regulatory
adjudicatory or administrative
function if that was intended to deal
with the situation that I think you
described representative Smith but if it
is not um then perhaps some language and
I'd be happy to try to draft it in
conjunction with uh commissioner little
um this was designed to solve that
problem the idea of this paragraph uh
four was to make sure that Regulatory
Agencies could continue to collect this
information if it was in their
Regulatory purview and certainly the
kind of activity that was described by
representative Smith is within the
purview of the banking
Department um thank you very much for
that I will just point out that that is
the exact language that the banking uh
department is challenging so um it might
be um if you could come up with
something that helps to satisfy the
banking department since we thought it
had been addressed that would be helpful
thank you very much for indulging me uh
Mr chairman I will make that effort
representative Smith representative B
question no I was simply going to point
out what uh representative Smith just
pointed out that the language in that
section referring to Ani an individual
is what the banking commissioner was uh
having problems with so no additional
question are there any other questions
for representative Kirk yes
representative
Langley representative Kirk I'm go I'm
looking at number five ran num
five and it says any person violating
provisions of this section shall be
guilty of a violation if a natural
person or guilty of a misdemeanor if any
other person how would I have any idea
or determine that my rights had been
provision I'm just I'm having a hard
time understanding how how the consumer
would know that um their rights have
been
violated section five representative
Langley deals with a Criminal
prosecution a violation is a criminal
act a misdemeanor is a is a punishment
for a criminal act so the individual
would not be prosecuting in that case
however section six six is perhaps the
one you're referring to a person who
suffers injury can sue um that's always
a problem in these situations it the
bill does nothing to um help an
individual determine whether his or her
rights have been violated and um I share
your concern I'm not aware of a method
to uh address that issue but certainly
if you found out that your name was
included in a database and the database
for example had not been authorized by
the legislature or if for example um you
were involved in some sort of
um relationship with a state agency and
they had information about you that you
hadn't provided and you believed that
they had gotten it elsewhere you could
inquire and ask how they got it and that
could form the basis for your suit but
to be very Frank it that's a difficult
situation much of the legislation we
pass how does one learn that his rights
have been
violated I'm sorry I don't have a better
answer thank you representative any
other
questions representa KK seeing none
thank you for your testimony today thank
you Mr
chairman uh
what we again we're behind schedule so
I'm going to ask everyone if they
could keep their testimony to three
minutes it would be greatly
appreciated and well since since there
have been inquiries in that regard I'll
call upon uh Piera doino attorney doino
I think to uh to speak next she's from
Department
hi my name is Kiara dolino I'm the
general counsel at the New Hampshire
banking Department um and as as you
heard uh the concern that the department
has and um we have presented testimony
commissioner little has testimony um
that he's presented for you
unfortunately he can't be here today um
the concern is with the provisions in
section um four Roman 4 in F proposed
d-h colon 2
um that provision we believe was
intended to permit Regulatory Agencies
to um engage in their usual practices of
obtaining information from third-party
providers however the language in that
provision that references a particular
individual is a concern because we often
in our examinations and in other uh work
do not request information about a
particular individual um we for example
would do an examination and request
um from a bank or other financial
institution um information about say a
period of Time how many loans uh give us
all the loans you've done within this
time frame we have no idea who the
consumers are for the information we're
obtaining we would have no way of having
those names before we ask for the
information so our concern is that that
provision would not allow us to do our
our usual work in examining Banks and
other financial institutions um the same
would apply if we're investigating
wrongful conduct we would ask the
institution please provide us with the
names of all and the information about
all consumers who might have been
impacted again we don't know in advance
the names of the consumers so we're not
asking for information about a
particular
individual so those are our concerns and
I'm happy to answer any
attorney seeing n thank you for your
test testimony today thank
you
Moore thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee U for the record my
name is Greg Moore and I am the state
director with Americans for Prosperity
New Hampshire and I am testifying today
in support of House Bill
597 AFP supports House Bill 597 which
protects the Privacy rights of New
Hampshire citizens the legislation
outlines several categories of personal
information that individuals would
retain priv a privacy interest in even
when that information is given to a
third party uh this bill really helps to
put meat on the bones of the new part
one article 2B which explicitly codifies
the right to privacy in New Hampshire's
Constitution veteran members of this
committee may remember that uh AFP
supported cacr 16 which moved through
house Judiciary in 2018 and eventually
became
part one article 2B this legislation
begins to put in place parameters for
that Amendment without waiting years for
the courts to develop case law as far as
the specifics of the bill in order to
benefit from technology like social
media and email we give information to
private entities constantly in 1979 the
US Supreme Court held that Americans had
no privacy interest in information that
they voluntarily gave to private
companies thus the numbers uh you call
on your cell phone your internet search
history and much more information that
regul passes through cell phone provide
providers and internet service providers
can be given to the state government
with or local governments without any
judicial oversight the expectations of
privacy Americans have in your data no
longer matches today's legal Reality
House Bill 597 changes that by adding a
warrant or subpoena requirement for
personal information that we we should
all have an interest in protecting this
will clarify privacy protections for
both law enforcement and the public in a
constructive way consistent with our
state's Constitution the Supreme Court
us Supreme Court has started to slowly
update Fourth Amendment Juris Prudence
to reflect the Norms of our increasingly
Digital Society but we need not wait for
the federal courts to inch towards
updating the Fourth Amendment as Justice
Alo said in the Riley versus California
case quote it would be very unfortunate
if privacy Protections in the 21st
century were left primarily to to the
courts using the blunt instrument of the
force Amendment legislatures elected by
the majority are in a better position
than we are to assess and respond to
changes that have already occurred and
those that most likely it will take
place in the future close quote uh we
think that house bill 597 is a a
statutory scalpel molding the Privacy
protections of people for of people in
the state in a valuable way it
recognizes the role the legislature has
in creating privacy protections would
also work in tandem with a new
constitutional amendment to clarify how
it would work in practice for those
reasons we support House Bill 597 and
urge the committee to find it ought to
pass um I'd be happy to take any
questions but I'd like to add that also
joining us today although not signed up
to speak is Billy Easley uh Billy is the
senior policy analyst and attorney who
handles technology and Innovation um
he's available to answer any technical
questions the committee might have while
I dabble in this issue he lives in this
world so I'd be happy to volunteer Billy
who's uh online as well so thank you so
much and I'd be happy to take any
questions from the committee are there
any
Mo seeing none thank you for your
testimony
okay uh thank you uh good morning uh my
name is Kyle Baker and I'm with the firm
wrath young and ping nalii and I'm here
on behalf of the internet Coalition in
opposition to House Bill
597 um I'll be very brief um we have
submitted some written testimony that
goes in- depth into our concerns um and
we just wanted to highlight a couple of
key points and some real world examples
where we think this legislation may have
some unintended consequences um our
members are keenly aware of our
customers expectations and rights of
privacy particularly when it comes to
their personal information uh digital
privacy is the focus of considerable
attention at the federal level which is
where we believe data security laws are
best addressed um technology does not
stop at the state border and a patchwork
of state laws will only lead to a
confusing and burdensome process for
both providers and consumers um two
quick real world examples that we
thought would be helpful in highlighting
some of our concerns um this legislation
um would forbid government agencies from
acquiring retaining obtaining or even
using an address telephone number or
email address of any person even for
basic um benign functions um such as
marketing or you know promotion of
things that state agencies are doing um
an example could be that the state parks
division wanted to promote changes at
one of its Parks or send out an update
of new park hours um section two of this
bill would specifically prohibit them
from using any contact info whether
there's a physical address email address
or phone number to invb the public
unless someone had specifically reached
out to the department looking for this
information um a second um concern and
examp example that we wanted to provide
is around the use of mailing lists
whether it's for online charity
fundraisers political or political
campaigning section three of this bill
would specifically prohibit um
government contractors or elected
officials from maintaining any sort of
personal information in a database that
wasn't specifically authorized by the
legislature um so with that I just will
wrap up and refer to our written
testimony and just say that the
protection of personal information
continues to be of utmost concern to the
internet Coalition and its members
however we believe that this bill would
do more harm than good it raises issues
of compliance for multi-state National
businesses but equally important in its
Simplicity raises issues of adequate
protection for consumers we would
therefore ask you to oppose this Bill
thank you for your time thank you any
other there any questions for Mr Baker
Baker seeing none thank you for your
testimony next person would be
Kathy
Stacy good morning Mr chairman can you
hear me good yes thank you I'm Kathy
Stacy I'm the Rockingham County register
of deeds and I am uh testifying neither
in support or nor in opposition however
we do as the Registries of Deeds do have
uh obviously Grant to a grantee indexes
that are available to the public and
third party vendors and everybody else
we're concerned about this bill um to
make sure that we are exempt um from the
uh obviously the violation of of what
these Provisions are to make sure that
we are absolutely covered because as you
know you can go online to basically all
10 counties and do whatever research you
wish and we have names we have addresses
you know that our index is by name only
but you can it's a guide to the
documents and you can look at documents
and you can get information about
Banking and you can get information
about addresses and and so forth so
we're concerned obviously to make sure
what type of liability this type of bill
is going to um cause the counties so
that's pretty much my testimony and I
will take any
questions thank thank you very much for
your testimony and other there any
questions Stacy seeing none thank you
very very much thank you very much have
Grace thank you Mr chair I'm n Grace
with the New Hampshire Municipal
Association uh obviously from
representative Smith's comments earlier
uh you you've received our written
testimony we do oppose this bill we are
concerned about the ambiguous language
um we
do to the to the extent that I can
respond to Mr Kirk's uh remarks earlier
um we are concerned that the way this
bill is written there that there would
be strict liability so that if there was
if there was a violation whether or not
intentional um that would be uh that
would result in liability attaching to
the government agency particularly for
us
municipalities and therefore um there
would be unintentional consequences um
and those are outlined in my written
testimony I'm more than happy to take
questions uh since I I am trying to keep
in mind how late the committee is
running thank you very much are there
any questions for attorney
Graves seeing none thank you again last
person who pre-registered to testify is
Maya
McKenzie thank you Mr chairman my name
is my name is Maya McKenzie and I'm
representing the state privacy and
security Coalition I am respectfully
testifying in opposition to HB 597 we've
submitted written testimony but I'd like
to highlight uh just a couple of
ambiguities in light of our time uh the
first is that this bill would create a
very ambiguous right expectation of
privacy and personal information uh but
there is great uncertainty around the
information to which this new right
would apply the bill creates the bill
applies to personal information content
and usage however content and usage are
undefined leaving both individuals and
disclosing entities alike without
clarity on what information is covered
by this proposed uh expectation of
privacy second uh this bill does not
appropriately consider the degree to
which federal law intersects and
protects many types of information that
are described in the bill such as health
information through Hippa financial
information with the Graham leech B act
and others the private right of action
that allows individuals to sue for
statutory damages if there has been a
violation for this vague and over raw
provision would lead to a surge in class
action litigation which rarely results
in recovery Plains in privacy related
claims but more importantly this
frustrates Public Safety efforts uh
first the exception uh to the private
right of action which applies to um
corporations would not apply to
disclosures to County agencies so
disclosures to County agencies such as
the sheriff or a nursing home would
result in a potential $1,000 per
violation p penalty plus attorney fees
second this exception only applies to
corporations exposing non-corporate
entities to class action risk so
organizations and public Charities like
New Hampshire's children trust which you
know advocates for uh Child Protection
should have the ability to make
disclosures that support the public good
without the threat of diverting
resources and funds to defend against
litigation um in the in this earlier
testimony the sponsor stated there would
be no litigation risk risk for
inadvertent or unintentional disclosures
in violation of the bill however there
is no such language in this bill that
would provide Clarity on that issue so
for these reasons we oppose respectfully
House Bill 597 and ask that you not move
forward thank you in advance for your
consideration on these matters and
please do not hesitate to reach out with
any
questions thank you for your testimony
is there any questions M
McKenzie seeing none thank you for your
testimon morning that concludes the list
of pre-registered there are a couple of
people who do have their hands up who
wish to testify first appears to be
Keller thank you Mr chairman and members
of the
committee um I excuse me I uh thank you
for entertaining my testimony and
opposition of HB 597 in his current form
um protection of unreasonable search and
seizures have been eroded over uh ever
since the electronic age started um
partic and that's because they're not
clear protections and safeguards in law
um Snowden revealed that there were
secret decisions that collection of
personal information didn't constitute a
search until they actually ran uh a
search on the information that was
collected
and there I I think uh representative
Langley for bringing up the issue that
we as individuals often don't know that
our rights have been violated um I
believe it was representative Langley um
that mentioned that and uh this
information really needs to
be uh kept private and uh the S search
warrant needs to be uh presented to the
the individual who's records are trying
to be searched so that they have an
opportunity to to challenge that the
reasonableness of the request and um so
I think that there is uh significant
potential
for erosion of people's uh privacy
rights if this bill was to pass in its
current form um there's currently
already a statute
644a that
addresses the protection of people's uh
location data and it does not seem that
this uh these protections listed in this
bill HB
597 uh reflect the the wise decision of
this the the state house and um to to
put those Protections in law and this
would actually open up what is currently
not allowed to be shared because this
bill has far more exceptions than is
currently allowed in
644a specifically The subpoena
requirement which only has uh a level
of uh requirement that the request is
not unreasonable oppressive and
excessive in scope whereas the
the the search warrant requirement
requires probable cause and
particularize suspicion also uh
644a expands on the 911 exception
and flushes it out so that instead of
using vague language it actually is
clear on what is allowed and what is not
also 644a addresses the emergency
exception in this bill it currently just
says an emergency and uh
644a flushes that out to what does that
actually mean and so um there's also a
broad exception for Regulatory Agencies
which has been uh hammered home uh I
think by previous testimony as being an
issue I incl conclusion I think that uh
we need to really address this issue in
conjunction with the and informed by
644a and the protection that offers
especially because it uh talks about in
this bill uh the location data um also
being protected and so it would be two
statutes addressing the same
uh issue with two different levels of
protection so I'm happy to uh work with
this this committee on this bill and the
sponsors and I hope that the that uh the
the committee would retain this and we
can work over the summer with the
different uh stakeholders and I'm happy
to take any questions thank you you any
y seean thank you for your testimony
today thank you for your patience
absolutely thank you okay and the next
head we're running way behind so if you
could try to make your testimony as
succinct as possible it would be greatly
appreciated great um thank you Mr
chairman thank you members of the
committee my name is Richard HED I'm the
government Affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch um I just wanted to
point to a written correspondence I had
previously filed relative to the effect
Ive date um I think this bill triggers
rsa1 14 colon 9-a which would um require
that the effective date be January 1
2022 instead of upon passage If This
Were to go forward um and and that's
basically to allow the judicial branch
the opportunity to with the hundreds of
changes that are made to update our
database systems to uh ensure that that
um notice has gone out to all la
enforcement regarding uh changes on
criminal code and this includes a
provision that that has criminal
penalties um secondly which is not
contained in my letter um I note that on
page two um where they have the
exceptions it refers to State agencies
or state departments and agencies um
that receive information as part of
their normal duties the judicial
branches is probably not a state agency
or uh Department um and probably should
be included within that list as
receiving on a on a regular basis
through pleadings and filings um
information that would be considered
confidential or personal information
with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you very much for your
time today thank you for your succinct
testimony any questions for attorney
head see none thank you thank you
there's one remaining hand up and then
we'll close the hearing that's Chris Gil
rain
thank you so much uh Mr chairman and I
will be very brief um I represent uh
techet we are a National Organization of
companies throughout the Innovation
economy uh just wanted to bring up one
particular point of concern for our
members uh it's unclear under the
legislation uh whether companies when
being uh requested information by the
state agencies
should refuse access or seek legal
counsel as to whether the request falls
under the agency's purview and therefore
be allowed under Roman numeral 4 uh
essentially concerned that this puts
them in a situation where they have to
choose between failing to comply with a
state request or risk litigation for
complying um that compounded with the
private right of action uh and that
makes the uh unclarity here uh
particularly concerning again thank you
very much for your Indulgence I we did
uh submit written testimony as well
thank you very much are there any
questions from Mr
G seeing none thank you very
much Mr chair the blue the blue um
sheet
yes although it's not
blue
is there are Aid and support
registered in support seven registered
in
opposition thank you one neutral which
registers so we'll close the hearing on
House Bill
297 which brings us to our last hearing
of the morning I'd like to take a break
but since there are people who appeared
here to
testify and they've been waiting a half
an hour I just assume go ahead with the
hearing if we can and get it done uh
limit the testimony if I can as best I
can to a couple of minutes for each
person this is so we'll open the hearing
on House Bill
288 I'm going to note that there are six
people who registered in advance in
support and 48 people who registered in
opposition and with uh and with regard
to the people who registered to test ify
11 people registered to testify and
every single one of them registered in
so the bill is the primary sponsor of
this bill is representative BOS and if
he is available we'll call upon him to
bill Mr chair if I could um the uh Prime
sponsor representative abbis told me
that representative Roy would be U
represent hello can you hear me yes we
can oh great thank you uh good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee I
appreciate you uh hearing the testimony
to open this bill this morning for the
record my name is representative Terry
Roy I represent Rockingham District 32
um chairman abbis grabbed me this
morning on my way to the gym so pardon
me if I seem a little unprepared for
this he got called away to an emergency
meeting he could not get out of um so
this bill HP 288 repeals RSA 679 the
housing appeals board the housing appeal
board was presented on its merits last
year and it failed to gain any ground
the policy was passed eventually because
it was included in the budget and to
avoid the government shutdown the budget
was voted for and it was included and
passed um barring some change in
circumstances um the governor has
represented that he would sign a bill
that would uh change this and if if it
made it to his desk eliminating this
board would save New Hampshire taxpayers
nearly half a million dollars per year
uh overwhelmingly the majority of
support for housing Bill board came from
Real Estate developers however these
developers created a board that follows
nearly the same procedures as the appeal
process if it were filed in Superior
Court one particular concerning section
of the housing appeals board statute RSA
679 col 7 Roman
2 the prime sponsor believes that this
would allow for land developers who was
has standing to transfer a petition
previously filed in the Superior Court
to the housing appeal board over the
objection of the petitioner who filed in
Superior Court provided the land
developer has standing um we do not need
this board at the state level making
decisions undermining local control of
our
communities and that's the introduction
for the bill representative abbis has
told me that he intends to be here
before the end of this hearing to take
questions thank you very much for your
do any of the committee members have
questions for representative
Roy see none again thank
you oh there he is
yeah good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
Bob G state senator District
2 and uh if you will the originator of
the housing appeals board ladies and
gentlemen the committee we exist to
solve problems in our state right now we
have a vacancy rate of
1% uh and people literally for example
on the headlines in the conquered
monitor this morning being thrown out of
their houses uh so that uh rents can be
raised certainly appropriate the problem
is we have no
inventory that is the result of a number
of problems systemically over the years
um not the least of which has been the
time it takes for developers to get
their projects through the
system um they go to a series of
meetings with respective land use boards
in the
community and if the land use board uh
declines to permit the project then what
happens is it goes to Superior Court if
the developer chooses to go this is a
process that's expensive time consuming
and very frequently results in the in
the um erosion of financial support
necessary to fund these projects bear in
mind this is this is not
about Section 8 housing this is about
Workforce housing and serving on finance
Ways and Means in the senate for now my
fifth year I can tell you that more than
a few companies that have looked to come
here good companies have declined to do
so because we have no housing stock part
of the problem for that is part of the
reason for that is that we've not been
able to build because much of our
projects are tied up in courts that take
time energy and
material this bill in no way allows a
contrary to the remarks of the previous
speaker allows someone to jump back and
forth between the courts and the housing
appeals boards very explicitly stated in
the legislation a person gets to choose
one or the other and if they choose the
one then any action in the other is
stayed and the
um uh the process moves forward what's
important in this in this panel is that
it has 180 days to arrive at a decision
it does not override decisions of
planning boards it does not establish
new laws it just merely makes certain
that planning boards and land use boards
abide by state laws on Workforce housing
and abide by their own ordinances in
more than a few instances this is not
been the case so this board now has two
cases before it I invite you to review
the letters submitted by the newly
appointed chair uh of the housing
appeals board uh and having now been
started and already seeing processes
moving forward that will significantly
expedite the construction of housing by
resolving these differences between
planning boards and developers without
having to resort to the court system I
would ask that you support uh the
housing appeals board and vote in
opposition to House Bill 288 and I will
take any
questions any questions for Senator
guid seeing no questions thank you for
your testimony today thank you Mr
President Mr
Barry
I'm sorry can you hear me again okay
great thank you uh Mr chairman I'm
Elliot Barry I'm the director of housing
Justice for New Hampshire legal
assistance where I've been practicing
law as it relates to housing in almost
every aspect for about 44 years um I
just want to be really quick about this
first of all I think a lot of the
opponents assume
that this board is going to be extremely
friendly to
developers um what I would suggest is
that look you have the three members are
appointed by the Supreme Court who I as
far as I know has never had an antioc
bias um and then the other member by
Statute is a land a land surveyor uh or
a uh an
engineer I think the they're applying
the same law that the Superior Court
would apply and I think the only reason
that more housing will be developed from
this is that projects will not go under
because of the time and expense of
Superior Court litigation and there's no
reason that development should not
happen because of the delays and expense
of litigation thanks to this the housing
appeals board legisl
people will not have to hire lawyers
decisions will generally be made within
a six Monon period The Rules of Evidence
won't apply and in fact you probably
have more expertise on the board than
you would in superior court because the
statute says that all these people have
to be experienced in uh land use
development or Housing Development a
great majority I think of the Superior
Court are people who are forers
Attorneys General
um who have no reasonably they have any
background in local land use laws so the
bottom line I mean the other thing that
just makes sense is that this board has
been up and running for about a month
maybe a month and a half you know would
I would urge you at very least to just
wait and see how it works I think it's
going to work everywhere every bit as
well as the board of land and tax
appeals on which it's based um but why
don't let's wait and see and the proof
of the pudding they say is in the pie or
whatever they say um so I just urge you
to uh vote itl on this
legislation thank you are there any
questions for attorney
Barry singan thank you again for your
Ju
yes Mr chair members of the committee
can you hear me okay can hear you fine
thank you uh for the record my name is
Dave juv I'm a senior vice president
with the business and industry
Association we're here in strong
opposition to this bill establishing the
uh housing appeals board was a top
priority for the
Bia um and we remain we remain um in
favor of that board with
uh attorney Barry just noted has barely
been up and running a month we think
that it will actually save the state
money not cost the state money by
providing a more expeditious and
inexpensive way to resolve a dispute
between uh housing developers and uh
municipalities uh the reality is
employers around the state are um having
a great deal of difficulty attracting
employees with the limited amount of
housing stock available for those
employees uh we um are fully supportive
of the housing appeals board we do think
it will work to help increase Workforce
housing throughout the state and we
would urge you to reject this uh Bill
I'd be happy to address any questions
thank you are there any qu yes attorney
MC uh representative MC Beth thank you
Mr chair and um thank you Mr D for
taking my question just from the past
two uh Witnesses we've heard that um you
know it's
consumers um W testimony that consumers
would not benefit you're saying that um
you know employers would not benefit who
is going to benefit if this bill is
repealed I mean Frank Frankly
representative I don't think anyone
benefits I don't think the
municipalities benefit because just if
you repeal this board that doesn't mean
these disputes are going to go away it
means they're going to have to uh be
decided upon in court which is expensive
both for the developer and for the
municipality not to mention the fact
that the one of the greatest advantages
of this um housing appeals board was
that it can act expeditiously on these
on these disputes and resolve them and
not have it dragged on for months and
system thank you for answering that
question and thank you Mr chairman any
other questions for Mr
juet singan thank you for your testimony
today thank you Mr chair again I'm going
just going to add that everybody who
signed up to testify is signed up in
opposition so hopefully if they testify
they can be succinct and just add new
information that might be helpful to us
Michael
can you hear me now we can hear you
thank you good morning Mr chairman and
members my name is Gregory Michael I
happen to be the chair of the housing
appeals board I was placed on the board
by the Supreme Court and confirmed by
the governor along with Elizabeth
Fischer and was still waiting our third
member but in the internet room we're
able to uh have uh surveyors and
Engineers who are selected and approve
by the Supreme Court to sit on an as
needed basis uh we've only been we've
only started in mid January we have two
cases filed and I will tell you that our
first trial is April 7th I think any of
you who are familiar with the court
system would recognize that that's quote
moving the ball down the court faing
rapidly our purpose is to do what you've
heard and that is to expeditiously
fairly and responsibly handle these
cases I've submitted a letter to the
board I would encourage the members to
read it I should say the committee to
read it I think it outlines some of the
thought that we have in analyzing RSA
679 the bottom line is as noted we
believe that it's important to keep the
keep the the projects moving in the
sense that if it's denied at the local
level we can take a look at it quickly
and make decisions that are fair and
appropriate and I would point out based
upon the local regulations and
ordinances I want to make it crystal
clear that I've heard rumors that
somehow we're some regulatory change
agent we are not we operate like the
Superior Court only more quickly and
with board members that have significant
expertise I've been involved in land use
and planning for over 40
years I've experienced every aspect of
it our real estate person Beth fiser has
been involved in real estate matters for
over 40 years and any of the surveyors
and Engineers that we select and use are
also experienced people the list of
names that I've submitted to the Supreme
Court to consider on a temporary basis
I've known them all for more than 30
years these are people I would like to
suggest will have the ability to quickly
promptly and fairly res review these
matters and I would point out that this
goes both ways I mean the municipalities
when they approve a project and it's
appealed by a Butters it's important
that it get resolved likewise if the
town or city did denies a project and
there's an issue with it we're going to
take a close look and if there's a
problem we can get the project back on
track and this is really the the the
fundamental difference between us and
the Superior Court we're trying to do it
quickly with expertise and as pointed
out at at a much less expense than
chasing your tail in Superior Court for
potentially a year or more dealing with
these
cases that's the summary of my my uh
remarks I don't want to take up more
time I know your time is limited today I
appreciate you hearing me out if you
have questions I'll be happy to answer
them representative MC Beth did you have
a
question
no I thank you I just didn't lower my
hand thank you so much Mr
chairman rep representative D Lorenzo
thank you Mr shair and thank you for
taking my question Mr Michael um
opponents of this legislation um say
that the housing appeals board takes
away local control what would you say to
that I would say that's absolutely a
false statement we do not take away
local control we are a different appeal
place to go you either come to us or the
superior court and I'll point out and I
agree with I believe Senator babbit that
testified there's no right to bounce
back and forth you make an election to
come before us or make an election to go
before the superior court and we do not
change local laws we do not change local
ordinances we operate under the
legislative scheme in each town and
municipality which is done now our
review is the certified record of what
the town the local Town board
experienced we don't take additional
evidence unless it's critically
important we operate on the certified
record and we do not change modify or
add to local zoning or planning
regulations those are left to the local
municipality ities as provided by State
Statute thank
you any other questions Miss Michael
yeah yes represent mlan um thank you
just just a quick question um the the
co-sponsor of the bill said that the
case could be moved from one ven venue
to another against a petitioner's will
but who gets to choose the original
venue do both parties have to agree to
the original venue or how is that
arrived at it's arrived that the
petitioner the person who's bringing the
appeal selects The Forum no different
than now if you have a case that could
be heard by the Circuit Court it can be
in the circuit court that same case
depending on the jurisdictional limits
might be heard in Superior Court so it's
the the petitioner the person appealing
selects the the location I would point
out that either party could make a
motion before us I suppose or before the
Superior Court to move it back and forth
that's going to require the consent of
both parties uh before that happens so
to answer your question it's the
petitioner that selects the trial
location representative Alexander um
thank you Mr chair um in your opinion um
Mr Michael is uh is is a is a ruling by
the housing appeals board have the same
kind of precedent or um case law
established well I I would point out
that the housing appeals board and
Superior Court are not considered courts
of record for judicial opinions that's
the state supreme court our orders have
the equivalent force and power of a
superior court order I would like to
make that clear we have the powers of a
superior court judge to rule and handle
these cases so our orders are equivalent
to superior court orders and to the
extent that people would like to review
our orders they certainly can but each
case would be decided on its own merits
based upon the facts and the law of each
municipality and that's the same
standard used by Superior
Court there any
other any other questions for attorney
Michael see thank you for your testimony
Frost
good afternoon Mr chairman thank you and
good afternoon committee members my name
is Ben Frost I'm the managing director
for policy and public affairs for the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
and I'm uh before you this afternoon to
express New Hampshire housing's
opposition to House Bill 288 and I'll
direct you to uh the letter that we
submitted from our executive director
Dean Kristen um which and I'm not going
to go into the details of that you're
free to read that on your own um and
most of what I wanted to say has already
been said so I won't repeat it so I'll
be even briefer than I intended um but I
I do want to point out that uh the
housing appeals board uh was based on
the structure and longstanding
performance of the New Hampshire Board
of tax and land appeals which has since
1973 admirably served the state of New
Hampshire and its citizens um the
housing appeals board is not a political
body uh given that its members are
appointed by the Supreme Court and it's
not subject to political influence which
I think is a a good design measure um
and emphasizing what chair Michael just
said about the issues of fairness uh the
housing appeals board was really
designed uh to be fair to all parties
involved uh as as a housing Advocate I
probably would have preferred a housing
appeals board to which only developers
could appeal but that would not have
been Fair and I think the legislature
recognized that and adopted legislation
that created a board that established a
board that is fair to
developers to Property Owners to
abutters anyone else who can demonstrate
standing in an appeal and yes to
municipalities for the foregoing reasons
and for reasons that others have stated
as well as the letter from New Hampshire
housing we respectfully request you to
itl House Bill 288 and I'd be happy to
take any questions thank you for your
testimony are there any questions for Mr
Frost seeing none again thank you next
Norwood good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Chris
Norwood I am the public policy chair for
the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors and I come before you today to
request you to itl this bill like others
have before for and I will be brief uh
just limiting to some new text as you
had requested Mr chair statistically uh
rents in the last five years are up 22%
according to the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority and according to our
statistics as the Realtors uh the median
price of a single family home is up
37% in those same five years uh the
balance of the data I just want to give
uh there was a question as far as um the
the costs in raising this is going to
raise uh fees for the state we believe
it's going to be a less expensive path
forward for both cities and towns and
also Agri AG grieved parties which is
really the last thing I'll say echoing
what Ben just mentioned is that we are
for property owners um yes we would like
to see more housing that's that is an
important challenge that our state is
facing together but we can't do it on
the backs of abutting property owners
and if you are an AG grieved abutter um
you you could have standing um I'm not
going to get into the details of who has
standing in and appeals but we feel that
this is a good path of remedy for all
parties who may have concerns uh be it a
developer or another party of standing
who wishes to challenge that development
uh so with that I will entertain any
questions and thank you for your time
any questions for Mr
Norwood seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you next person is
Alisa
margin thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is marglin I serve as
director of housing action New Hampshire
we a Statewide Coalition of 80
organizations United around affordable
housing policy and ending homelessness
in New
Hampshire um we are opposed to House
Bill 288 um and uh to just provide new
information uh per your request Mr
chairman um housing action New Hampshire
was one of several stakeholders who have
been working on this proposal for
several years uh for our members our
members include those who um develop
finance and manage affordable housing
around the state of New Hampshire um
we're expressing concerns about um delay
tactics that were driving up the cost of
providing housing as Mission oriented
developers who want to pass on a more
affordable property uh to those uh
seeking a home that they can afford um
adding uh the delays and costs
associated with the traditional uh
revieww process um is not an option for
our developers as they cannot pass along
those additional costs uh to their um to
their consumers um so there was this
absence of Justice uh in in fact they
just in many cases did not appeal I'd
also like to make the point that the
housing appeals board does not uh in any
way mean that um that those reviews will
uh be in favor of of the developer um as
we have seen in the uh longstanding
Bureau of tax and land appeals it is
simply a more efficient uh and more
effective uh appeal mechanism um so that
our Judiciary can uh prioritize uh their
case load um and with that I'll conclude
my
testimony thank you are there any
questions from miss
margolin seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today there are four people who
pre-registered still haven't spoken who
Marino hi can you hear me we can hi
thank you so much Mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee um I'll be
very brief because I know the committee
is running behind and uh uh much of what
I said in my testimonies has been said
and I submitted some written testimony
as well so um all I'll say is uh my
name's Marino um I work for an
organization called 603 forward we are
um a youth advocacy organization um and
one of our priorities is to promote
affordable housing in New Hampshire to
help attract and retain more young
people to our states um repealing the
housing appeals board um would be very
detrimental to the goal of um promoting
affordable housing and attracting more
young people to our state um we believe
that the housing appeals board has been
a reasonable reform um that um helps
expedite the the process for appeals um
and um helps pave the way for more
affordable housing so we strongly urge
you to um uh support an itl
recommendation for HB 288 um and I'm
very grateful for your time today thank
you Mr chairman thank you for your brief
testimony any questions from Mr Marino
saens good afternoon Mr chair and thank
you my name is Jason sorens of Amherst
New Hampshire and I am also director of
the center for ethics at St anom college
and our Center and I myself do a lot of
housing policy research and um I'll
stick to uh a couple of original points
that previous speakers have not
addressed um one is that um ecomist have
found that uh local regulatory barriers
to building new homes is really the main
reason in why New Hampshire is facing a
critical
undersupply of Housing and those
regulatory barriers are not just those
codified uh in black and white on paper
in fact uh to a substantial degree they
they consist of the the discretionary
decisions of local land use boards it's
not unknown for a local land use board
to uh take um an illegal decision to
block um a potential development perhaps
because of the the fears of of a Butters
or simply they don't like the project
and uh the developers the property
owners who are most deterred by
challenging uh those sorts of decisions
are the small landowners um big
developers may have legal departments or
lawyers on retainer who can um take
these these cases to court um but very
often a smaller landowner think of a
farmer subdividing his his property into
a handful of single family home sites um
may may simply look at this um barrier
and say no no thanks I'm not going to
take the cost and the delay of pursuing
this fight in the
courts and the other point I would make
is that the housing appeals board is
actually um fairly Innovative it's it
fits a model of appeals boards that we
have here in New Hampshire but other
states are also looking at the our
housing appeals board uh specifically I
was invited recently to participate in a
panel um by the Manhattan Institute
which is the free market think tank in
New York um on a paper that is on New
Hampshire's housing appeals board and um
other land use Scholars are looking at
this as a model that other states could
adopt to help make it so that we at
least um know that the regulatory
barriers that are preventing new housing
are the ones that are actually written
down on paper um so this doesn't
actually repeal any regulations but it
simply makes it so that um those
regulatory barriers that do exist are
transparent um thank you and I'm happy
to take any questions thank you are
there any questions from Mr
sens seeing none thank you thank you
[Music]
North
yeah if you're out
there you need to raise your hand y
there we go yeah I got a I finally got
the unmute thing people hear me now we
can good thank you um I appreciate the
opportunity to uh Express uh my feeling
that that um this bill HP 288 um should
not move forward uh we are uh I am a
business owner I'm not part of um a
number of the um the um important groups
that were represented earlier um I run a
business I have 21 employees here in
Portsmouth
um I have five employees that are under
the age of
35 of those five employees one lives in
the state of New
Hampshire two live in Massachusetts and
two live in Maine that's all stemming
from a florid ability and frankly if it
hadn't been for a a little bit of uh
Fortune uh Good Fortune I would have
lost the employee that was that
currently lives in New Hampshire um the
housing shortage is a critical one uh
for us business owners it's a critical
one for this uh the future of the
economy of New Hampshire um anything
that helps address that problem is going
to help the businesses and the citizens
of our state business-friendly New
Hampshire is a housing friendly New
Hampshire and vice versa I thank you
very
much thank you for your testimony any
questions for Mr
Sturman seeing none again thank you and
the final person who pre-registered to
turny if you're out there please raise
your hand there we
go hello this is uh Robert turny and I'm
the executive director at neighbor workk
Southern New
Hampshire and I think one of the
unmentioned uh um folks that that will
be impacted by this and hopefully
benefit from this um our homeowners I I
we're an affordable housing developer
but the when the bill was introduced um
it's the sponsor mentioned that it was
going to benefit developers and I think
it's important to mention and recognize
that
um single family homeowners in
municipalities of to encounter some many
of the same challenges that developers
do and they certainly don't have the
wherewithal to pursue uh a challenge
through the court system and i' just
like to give one example as an
affordable housing developer of an
example where I had a planning board
chair look me straight in the eye and
say there's no conditions in our
planning ordinance in our ordinance that
will require us to put these conditions
on the approval of your project but
nonetheless since it was brought during
the approval process we're going to make
you adhere to them and I have to then
take the take that recommendation and
that decision and decide do I want to
move forward with my approvals and spend
the extra $100,000 on our project that
this is going to cost us or do I want to
not accept it and go through the lengthy
judicial lengthy and expensive judicial
process um and I had no choice I felt
like I had no choice because I could not
afford the time delay that would be
associated with a legal Challenge and so
so we agreed to accept the conditions
and pay the $100,000 in additional
construction costs that that put on our
project had something like the land use
appeals board been in place at that
point in time I probably would have been
able to come forth with a different a
different uh decision and affect my
project differently and had not had been
so expensive so I really want the
committee members to take that into
consideration and hope that you will um
itl this Bill thank thank you for
hearing my points today thank you Mr
attorney any question questions from Mr
attorney seeing none thank you again
there are two other people who have
raised their hands who wish to speak on
this bill n gra is also on the
list did I miss somebody yeah he was on
testify sor
turny turn off your
po can you hear me Mr chairman you can
great uh good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee I'll be very
brief I'm aric I'm an attorney and
lobbyist for the New Hampshire Home
Builders Association
I've been a lobbyist uh and u a land use
attorney in New Hampshire for over 20
years I just want to join the chorus as
a longtime stakeholder and strong
supporter of the housing appeals board
uh we strongly oppose repeal and
therefore oppose this bill we ask that
you itl the bill uh the housing appeals
board can only help and not hurt the
state that's in the midst of a Workforce
housing crisis and uh we appreciate uh
the desire to be fr with the taxpayers
money which seems to be the motivation
of the sponsor but this expense is
worthwhile it's already part of the
state budget IT addresses a priority
item and the housing appeals board is is
just in its infancy and should be given
a chance to perform thank you very much
for taking my testimony thank you for
your brief testimony any
questions Mr Po attorney po see on thank
you there's somebody with their hand up
be thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
you can excellent thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee uh my name is
Will Stewart I'm the executive director
of stay workor play New Hampshire excuse
me which is a Statewide nonprofit whose
mission is to attract and retain more
young people here in the granite state
and I'm here today to speak in
opposition to House Bill 288 others have
spoken about the particulars of the
housing appeals board and why it's a
good idea I just want to speak for a
minute about about the need to do
everything we can to make housing more
affordable for young people and everyone
here in New Hampshire and not to make
the housing affordability situation even
worse so attracting and retaining more
young people is critical to the future
of our state you know New Hampshire as
you may know is the second oldest state
in the country with one of the lowest
unemployment rates on top of this we're
the number one exporter of high school
graduates seeking a four-year degree
with some 62% of these young people
leaving the state every year some of
them come back but a lot of them don't
in short New Hampshire needs all the
people we can get in general and all the
young people we can get in particular
and our businesses you know they need
workers and customers as we've heard our
towns need volunteered board members our
nonprofits our churches our Civic clubs
all need volunteers to accomplish their
vital missions without which our
communities and our state just can't
function about three years ago stay work
play commissioned a survey to collect
data on why young people stay in and
might leave New Hampshire and the number
one reason we found that young people
might leave is that they just can't
afford to live here our housing both on
the rental side side and on the home
ownership side is just too expensive and
we heard this over and over again last
winter uh as we talked to young people
in nine locations across the state as
part of our policy and pint Series so
you know housing here in New Hampshire
is expensive for just about everyone but
it's especially exp expensive for young
people who by being in their early in
their careers generally make less money
than their more experienced counterparts
and young people also face the
additional burden of student loan debt
indeed New Hampshire has one of the
highest average student debt loads in
the country and so you when you're
paying hundreds of dollars a month in
student loan payments every month it
makes it that much harder to afford
housing that's already expensive so you
know for these reasons we ask you to
oppose House Bill 288 and to retain the
housing appeals board which will help to
make housing less expensive here in New
Hampshire thank you thank you are there
any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to
testify seeing no hands
we will close the hearing on House Bill
FN which brings us to the end of our
morning
doc yeah uh I guess the question and Jen
if you're on the line is it possible to
put up a message that indicates that we
would reconvene for our hearing on 478
at
1:5 yeah we can do that okay then I
think that that's a good idea give
people enough time to take a little bit
of break anyway so if you would mind
putting that message up and uh we will
recess our today's hearing until
everybody
[Music]
right
here
all
call this meeting of the house officiary
comme
back we are scheduled this afternoon to
478 this is relative to treatment of
past contaminants in the drinking water
of the marac Village Water
District representative Mooney Morin
money is the primary sponsor and we'll
call upon representative Mooney to
Bill thank you very much Mr chairman is
everybody able to hear me we
are perfect well for the record my name
is Morin money a state representative
for the town of maram
in Hillsboro County district
21 I'm the prime sponsor of House Bill
478 an act relative to treatment of past
contaminants in the drinking water of
the miramac Village Water District I am
in support of this
bill I just want to highlight for the
committee that the co-sponsors on this
bill represent a cross-section of
legislators from both parties
in leadership from across the state as
well as in miramac and those of us in
marac behind the bill solidly could not
be more pleased with the bipartisan
collaboration and
cooperation in efforts to pass House
Bill
478 I just want you to be aware that
there will be several testifying after
me who bring to the table extraordinary
Technical and historic knowledge and
expertise on this very vast issue I'd
also like to point out to the committee
that last night I emailed to you my
testimony and what I did in that
document is that I categorized my
testimony into headings to try to make
this as clear and concise as I can so
I'm going to start now with the
background on this
bill the town of miramac has undergone
what is considered the worst case of
environmental pollution in the state's
history the town has spent years
reacting to this news of the effects of
P contaminants in clean air drinking
water groundwater waste water and
soil a detailed summation of that
history starting in
2016 is found in this bill in section
one Roman numerals I through 7 1 through
7 to give some background on my
involvement with this
marac asked that I
work with the meramac citizens for clean
water on two legislative initiatives
this
session M as a result I am the prime
sponsor of House Bill
478 additionally I know that members of
the marac citizens for clean water will
be testifying today in
support the next category of my
testimony is a summary of the
bill in some the bill extends the
operations and maintenance remedy in the
March
agreement between the miramac Village
Water District and St gobain performance
plastics for the miramac Village Water
District Wells number four and number
five I have a reference there where it
can be found in the bill if you have
that in front of you and it's easier
8 as it stands now and today such
operations and maintenance costs will be
paid by St
gban only through
2025 representing the first five years
of the water treatment system
operation House Bill
478 calls for St Goan to pay and this is
a quote from the bill all costs
associated with the continued operation
monitoring and maintenance and any
necessary additional modifications there
too and all additional incidental
operation and maintenance costs of Wells
four and
five beginning on October
27th
2025 and
continuing for so long as the aramac
Village Water District treats water in
Wells four and
five to comply with any existing or
future water quality standards set for
p and that can be found in the bill
section two Roman
2 line three on my
version it's important to note here that
the October 2025 date is five years from
the October 2020
activation of what is called a granular
activated carbon filtration treatment
system in Wells four and
five the next header on my testimony are
the
standards as to the standards for
keeping the wells what is called online
House Bill 478 refers to the P standards
effective in July of
2020 and those standards can be found in
RSA
485 colon 16 little
e again this can all be found in my
testimony additionally House Bill 478
men mentions in section 2 Roman
2 that remedial payments occur for so
long as the miramac Village Water
District treats water in Wells four and
five to comply with any existing or
past next category of my testimony is
rationale
of which I have three
points number one the town of
marac and surrounding area believe in
holding
pollutants
accountable and this bill will
accomplish
that number two the bill references an
April 1st 2016 letter from the
Department of Environmental services to
S gobain signed by the
commissioner in that letter on page
three the department formally requests
St
gobain to
quote provide for the necessary
long-term
operation maintenance and monitoring of
the installed treatment
systems this house bill will fulfill
that Department of Environmental
Services
demand my third point of
rationale is that the town of
miramac Andor The meel meramac Village
Water
District cannot incur costs in
perpetuity to filter polluted water from
an industrial
polluter although Dees deres its
authority to enforce its April 1st 2016
letter from and the citation there is
RSA 485 hyphens colon
3 Dees has not taken enforcement
action this bill will directly place the
costs of
operations monitoring and and
maintenance on the
polluter as Dees has
intended in its April 1st
letter the last and final category of my
testimony is my
conclusion in
conclusion we that is the town of
meramac ask that you not look at this
bill through the
of overregulation or state
mandate rather we ask that you envision
the circumstance if this bill does not
pass if this bill does not pass then at
midnight on October
2025 meramac citizens will be in the
unprecedented
position where by MVD
customers that is meramac
citizens will be forced to Bear the
costs to pay for a private industry's
cleanup while that industry is allowed
to continue to
pollute this unfortunate scenario then
results in an additional undue burden on
Mar ma
citizens as well as a precedent where
citizens are forced to
pay through the miramac Village Water
District to prevent private
pollution simply a scenario and a
precedent we cannot
set I would respectfully ask that the
committee vote House Bill 478 ought to
pass and with that I'm going to to
conclude my testimony and I want to
thank you once again for your attention
and your service thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative M and
representative bur do you have a
question yes I do and thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Mooney for taking my question and it's
it's kind of the
overarching um question about contracts
and enforcement of settlement agreements
and the like and as I understand it um
there's been
pollution in in that
area um it was believed that s Goan caus
the pollution Z Coan says no you know we
didn't do it all the pollution or some
of the pollution or whatever percentage
may be and eventually a settlement
agreement was
reached um both sides got something out
of this settlement agreement the uh
marabac got uh to avoid the litigation
about who's liable for the damage could
go right into the solutions save years
of uh of litigation costs and time Etc
and um the uh St Coan got a
defined uh obligation out of the
situation am I correct in understanding
that um what you would like done is
ripping up that
agreement but keeping the
admission uh so to speak by St Goan of
their
liability and just saying you guys are
liable and you're just going to have to
pay everything or do you EV Vision uh
going back to what the situation was
before the agreement which was to
issues thank you for the question I
would answer that by saying we'd like to
see the agreement extended beyond that
date and that is again that all costs
associated with the operation monitoring
and maintenance and additional
modifications be covered by St
gobain uh since the time of that
agreement
too the standards of July 2020 have gone
into effect there's certainly a chance
before 2025 that the standards will
change
again and I go back to my conclusion in
that uh the customers of the marac
Village Water District cannot not be
placed in a position to pay for a
private industry's
pollution thank you if I could follow up
may if you get what you
want which is to change the terms of the
settlement doesn't St
Goan have a right to go back and say no
settlement we're going to litigate
whether we're uh liable for this damage
and what percentage of the damage we're
liable
for I would say they would consider
and if I that's acceptable to you to
start the process
over well uh certainly I would like it
if they didn't but uh so far marac has
had difficulty controlling any actions
of Sy Oban so I can't focus too much on
what they will or will not do uh my
focus is making sure that the taxpayers
of miramac don't bear costs of Private
Industry
pollution thank you representative mlan
yeah thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question just to kind of
follow up a little bit on where
representative Burch was going since
there was this settlement and there was
an agreement um if if new information
has come
forward why why would you not pursue um
uh further redress in the courts what
what is making you pursue a legislative
solution um as opposed to uh going back
to the courts
again thank you that's a good and very
reasonable
question um a few
things recent headlines have once again
highlighted the difficult ulty the town
of miramac has had uh with negotiations
with st gobain it's
unfortunate however uh those in the
citizens for clean
water former speaker Hench and myself
and others who worked so diligently on
this bill including the co-sponsors felt
Avenue representative
Paige
yes I I think um rep thank you for
taking my question Mr and allowing me
the opportunity Mr chair I think uh
representative mlan may have touched on
part of my question but I'm wondering if
representative Mooney could elaborate
just a little bit more anything uh has
the extent to which things have changed
since um the town entered in the
settlement agreement on March 28th
2018 to now in terms of things that were
perhaps uncovered that would
um more damage
more um things that weren't known at
that time when you entered the
settlement agreement or could not have
time thank you for that that's a very
good question as well and um I would I
would refer you to that section RSA 485
colon 16 hyphen e uh it's cited in my
testimony under the standard section
uh there will be individuals testifying
after me who worked on that as those
went into effect those standards maximum
contaminant levels those standards went
into effect July 23d
2020 and so they could certainly get
into the details of
that um I believe another part of your
question was with regards to those who
who made the
agreement and the commissioners of The
marac Village Water District are
elected and so those that um entered the
agreement are not there at this time
Commissioners are there any other
questions
for
represent if I if I could just inquire
this is sort of a followup to the prior
questions and and that is
agreement and I guess the question that
I have is do you have any reason to
agreement thank you for
that I think in light
of what's come about since
in light of uh St gobain not being
cooperative and not just water but now
it's air filtrations and so
forth I think it's justifiable to say
that a bill of this nature would be an
appropriate Avenue in this instance to
look out for the best interest of the
representative okay thank you very much
for your testimony
today thank
you we have I just for the committee's
benefit I note
that 145 people signed up in support
three people signed up in opposition and
two people signed up as neutral and we
do have 12 people to testify today
and one of those people who did sign up
to testify is Senator Gary Daniels if
he's
available I think you may be muted
Senator yes I was thank you Mr chairman
uh good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Gary Daniels and I am the state
senator for District 11 encompassing the
towns of ammer marac Milford and Wilton
I appear you before you today in support
of and co-sponsor of House Bill
478 uh let me start by saying that I'm a
big advocate for businesses because
businesses are the vehicle to produce
jobs and make Prosperity possible for
all New Hampshire citizens but while I
advocate for businesses I do expect that
those businesses will operate in a
proper and responsible way including the
treatment of their employees and taking
the initiative to ensure that no harm is
done to the environment in the
production of the products they make or
the services they offer I support this
bill because my constituents in marac
have suffered harm from contaminants
created by s goban in the manufacturing
of its products and secondly because the
company has not fully mitigated nor in a
timely manner responsibly address the
pollution it has created and the harm it
has done to the marac community because
of the inaction by Sangle Bane including
its rebuff of the marac Town Council in
upholding its
responsibilities uh I feel that it
therefore becomes necessary for this
legislature to hold sangoan accountable
for rectification of the damage it has
brought upon the mar M community and I
don't do this lightly uh but I have seen
the frustration uh as the Town Council
Works to find resolution to this and I
have seen the stalling that has gone on
on behalf of the company uh in doing it
the responsible thing and uh upholding
its part its responsible part of the
cleanup so I therefore uh respectfully
ask that the committee vote ought to
pass on House Bill
478 thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your testimony so there any questions
senator see none thank you
again there is another sponsor who
signed up and that is represented
Rosemary
rum good afternoon can everyone hear me
you can
great thank you very much for the record
my name is representative Rosemary rung
and I represent marac which is in
Hillsboro County 21 I come before you in
support of HB
478 and I bring many perspectives to
this discussion first I am a 38y year
resident of miramac and also a 38-year
customer of the miramac Village Water
District I've served on the resources
committee which hears many water related
and pasas related business Bill s and I
currently chair the HB 737 commission to
study the environmental and health
impacts of
pasas as you know from reading the bill
SLE Bane performance plastic marac
operation has caused pasas contamination
of our groundwater groundwater which
serves as the sole source of mvds water
supply this contamination is the largest
industrial contamination in the history
of New Hampshire impacting not only
miramac but many surrounding communities
the level of pasas contamination exceeds
not only the EPA advisory limits but
also the New Hampshire maximum
contaminant levels when this
contamination was first discovered in
2016 MVD Commissioners scrambled to get
a Filtration plant built and reached a
short-term settlement with SLE bang to
provide Financial Resources to do so we
have since learned since that that
settlement that the financial resources
necessary far exceeds what was initially
agreed upon studies conducted since the
settlement particularly a Minnesota
study on the effects of pasas on infants
shows a causal relationship so serious
that it led the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services to recommend
far stricter standards than what was
initially proposed for the maximum
contaminant levels so the responsibility
of providing safety drinking water has
grown
significantly thus the question before
us is who holds this
responsibility obviously SLE ban their
chemicals leave their plant and enter
our groundwater and they should bear the
responsibility and cost of removing them
but who should hold them to this
responsibility I contend that it is the
state of New Hampshire after all it is
the state that has entered into statute
maximum contaminant levels
and that was just done a year or two
ago and it is the state that regulates
and enforces these standards on
Municipal Water Systems the state should
have the responsibility to hold Seno
Bane responsible for removing their
chemicals from our public drinking water
for as long as those chemicals risk the
health of our citizens and this is why I
recommend to the Judiciary Committee and
ought to pass motion on HB
478 thank you and I would be happy to
answer any
questions representative
bur thank you Mr chairman and and thank
you
representative um I want to go back to
your statement where you ask and answer
the question the question before us is
who holds this responsibility obviously
St
gobain um from a legal point of view
that is based solely upon the
agreement uh
that now you suggest be ripped up uh are
you also comfortable with stco Bane
having the right to go back and litigate
what uh level of liability they should
have whether it's 100% 50%
75% and secondly the amounts of money
that St gobain has spent in detrimental
Reliance on this agreement which is
probably right now in the millions uh is
that money going to be
refunded uh at this point to uh s Goan
by
marac well let me um kind of puts things
in perspective about s Goan um in 2020
they had a net income of
$1.75 billion dollar so when we talk
about any money they've spent in marac I
think we have to put it in context to
the overall income that the company
provides um but I I look at this bill in
a way kind of separate from the
settlement the settlement is in place it
was negotiated in good faith by both
parties and it has an expiration date um
but if I could use an analogy
representative Birch to help you
understand the situation imagine that
you had a a nextdoor neighbor okay maybe
it was a convenience store maybe it was
uh um you know grocery store whatever
and their trash continued to blow on
your property and you reached an
agreement with them that for five years
they have to clean up and and and they
have to absorb the expense of cleaning
up that
trash now the five years is over but
unfortunately their trash is they have
not remediated that and the trash is
still blowing on your property who's
responsible for enforcing that do you do
you have to go back to court to have a
settlement but shouldn't the town or the
mun IP ality who has litter ordinances
be the responsible party for cleaning up
that litter for forcing your neighbor to
clean up that litter why should you be
the enforcer of of laws and ordinances
that's the responsibility of government
that is why I believe that it's very
appropriate for the state and for the
general court to um Force SLE ban to
take responsibility for its
contamination and the cost of it therein
I hope I answered your
question um I don't think you answered
either part of the question that's okay
I I get where you come from yeah this
the settlement agreement is you know it
it it's an agreement it's it's isolated
it has a be begin date it has an end
date there are costs that have been
covered by Seno Bain but even with or
without that settlement agreement SLE
Bane is contaminating groundwater
they're violating the state's maximum
contaminant levels so who who should
comply thank you uh representative mcque
yeah thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um with
respect to uh the original settlement a
lot of light information has come to
light which would make you want to
revisit that and I can complete
completely understand that um I guess
the concern I have is with the
legislative solution I think what what
this sort of does is maybe sets up a
situation where everybody who is
polluting in the future we we could
maybe have 200 or 100 cases where we
have to have this as opposed to allowing
them uh to go through the courts um so
what makes and I don't think he would be
advocating that every case of a polluter
would have to come to the legislature so
what what makes this so special that in
this particular case it has to fall
outside of the courts and you have to
pursue that legislative
remedy uh well thank you very much for
your question I think the big game Cher
in my mind is the establishment by the
state of New Hampshire of Maximum
contaminant levels for Four Past
chemicals um we now have that in statute
um the these drinking water standards
and um those are enforcable by Dees and
so I look at it that Dees or the state
should ensure the enforceability of
those standards now those standards in
miramac are being violated because of
the direct contamination by SLE Bane so
it's my opinion that the state should
compel SLE Bane to um absorb the cost of
removing those contaminants to the level
requirement you want to follow up just
just just so if if as a result of the
new standards and thank you for taking
my followup question but if as a result
of the new
standards we find 10 additional
polluters would all 10 of those
polluters then have to be brought before
the general court or should they have to
go through the courts um what is your
thought on that uh my thought is um I
would like to see Dees enforce the these
standards I mean it's unfortunate that
um the mayor M Village District had to
reach a had to to enter into a
settlement agreement with senle ban in
the first place it should be the state's
responsibility um we have a department
of environmental standards it should be
their respons responsibility to compel
and force polluters to clean up their
contamination um I I think if had that
been done when Dees first issued a
consent agree um against St gobain we
would have never been in this position
but um as I said in my testimony at that
time um people in miramac were frantic
um we were drinking water we were making
formula we were showering in water that
exceeded even the Environmental
Protection agency's Health advisory um
so it was it was a desperate time to do
what we could to as soon as we could to
get that water cleaned up um at that
time I don't think we had the
information that we had now um I think
if we did that settlement agreement
would have um lasted as long as it takes
to get the water cleaned up but it was
only issued for five years and during
that time more information about the
dangers of F has have come to light but
um you know it's my opinion that the
state of New Hampshire Bears the
responsibility of forcing companies to
comply with their regulatory
requirements not municipalities and not
water districts okay thank you very much
thank you thank you for the question
representative
syvia thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
representative
um just to get a little more background
and and fill in the context could you uh
two parts could you tell me about when
uh st gobain came to marac then at the
time that uh it was coming was it
encouraged by the town of marac or was
it uh
protested um oh I think maram uh thank
you very much for the question by the
way I think marac welcomes all
businesses um you know we've got major
Employers in town Fidelity Investments
anheiser bush has a brewery in marac we
have wonderful restaurants I invite all
of you to come and enjoy everything that
marac has to offer um SLE ban I don't
exactly remember the dates and I'm sorry
I don't have that information with me um
but uh they came to miramac um they had
bought a facility um that had been
previously a manufacturer of GE jet
engines and when they came into marac
they were actually a company called
chemfab which had operations in um
Bennington Vermont in HK Falls New York
and they came uh to marac and then uh
SLE ban bought Kemp bab and made it part
of their performance Plastics division
um we did not know at that time um that
um their air emissions uh contain such
hazardous chemicals in fact at that time
I don't think even scientists knew the
the the hazards of past to the extent
that they know them now um and they
weren't regulated those past chemicals
and and they're still not really
regulated on a federal level Al although
I believe that's coming so it was really
up to the states to um to regulate them
um but but we welcomed um SLE ban um but
you know no matter how you know how many
employees they hire or employ or or
things they do um they're contaminating
or drinking water and they're doing it
to this
day I don't know I forget if I answered
both those questions I'm sorry about
that the other part was just about when
they came but that's all right if I
could follow up Mr chairman briefly you
may follow up um I assume that over the
time that sang gobain has been there
they have certainly
uh contributed largely to the community
the uh pay of workers are probably
housed locally there would that be the
case uh oh I'm sure there were sanco
Bane employees here
um and you know I
mean I think I mean all anything they
could do they're they've poisoned our
water um past levels in our water cause
infant uh low birth weight premature
birth weight um they've been linked to
several cancers New Hampshire has the
highest incidence of pediatric cancer
we've learned a lot about the health
impacts of past from what's going on at
the P's trade port in a history of
firefighting Foams so um I'm not willing
to settle uh for poisoned drinking water
just to have a good employer in town I
think any employer that's going to
pollute the a basic necessity of life is
not a good employer no matter how many
people they employ no matter how many
salaries they pay or Community donations
they make um safe drinking water has to
be a fundamentally protected
resource for our
communities thank you thank you
representative
bur uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Rong I just had a a
question to clarify something in my own
mind you refer uh
throughout uh this agreement is a
shortterm settlement and I'm puzzled so
perhaps you can explain
um is the settlement
itself uh Limited in time or just the
obligation of St Goan to do certain
things are limited uh to five
years uh well what is oh thank you for
um I'm getting some feedback can you
hear me okay yes okay must be on my end
um the the settlement agreement allow
for St gobain to cover some of the
operating and maintenance expenses for
five years that's the that's the gist of
it after that the burden of continuing
the cost of those uh filtration um
operations lies on on miramac Village
district and we're contesting that um
because pasas is a forever chemical
because it it is still present in the
water coming into those Wells that um
that even after that settlement
agreement expires Senco Bain should bear
the responsibility of cleaning up that
water so that it meets the state's U
mandated um maximum contaminant levels
if you you could if if I may follow up
yeah you confuse me in your language
about when the settlement agreement
expires that's not the same I believe as
the obligation of St goar to remediate
expire s the agree the settlement
agreement is in perpetuity is it not um
you know I I have to go back and check
and unfortunately I'm not in my office
um I I have some I I I'm um I I'm on
some personal business so I I don't have
all my files with me but um my
understanding and there's probably
others that are going to testify that
have answers to this question is that
SLE Bane is not taking necessar neily
the responsibility for
remediation they're just contributing
monies and even the monies they're
contributing are finite it's not uh it's
a set amount it's it's they're not
covering the exact cost they're they're
giving so much money and that those
monies go away after five
years thank you representative P thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative rung for taking my
question if you're not the right person
for this question then um you can defer
me to who might be in the testimony
later um I want to go back to the moment
in time when the settlement agreement
was made you described um kind of a
chaotic situation in marac given the
sort of desperation I think you said and
I know you weren't part of the
settlement agreement and I'm just in I
was reading a testimony from someone who
was in the water district that sent a
letter that said on advice of town
counsil he's not going to testify uh
today but perhaps you can tell us a
little bit you said the past science has
changed since then the knowledge I'm
wondering if there's anything that you
know of that at that time St gobain knew
about past that you didn't know that
would have been incred would have been
material to the length of their
obligation and you may I don't expect
you would know this but but maybe you do
or can point us to someone that might
sort of material information about the
nature of
pasas that might that might change sort
of the The Horizon for Our
obligation thank you very much for that
question representative um one of the
things that um I became aware of after
the settlement agreement was reached is
that the town of husk Falls New York um
where s gobain had had had also
contaminated uh with pasas um they had
reached an agreement with who Falls that
provides for long-term remediation I
don't even I think it's in perpetuity
but don't quote me on that um and
they're covering the cost it's not like
a set amount so I felt um they knew when
they went into that settlement agreement
that the cost of remediation is much
much higher I think uh and this is just
my opinion but I felt that they took
advantage of our desperation to get
clean drinking water because you have to
imagine Wells four and five are the
largest producers of the marac village
dist District so um this was a big
concern for people in miramac had we
known at that time that Seno bang was
already aware of and had already entered
into agreement with the town in New York
and had provided much High much more
considerable support for their water
cleanup and taken much more
responsibility I think our NE our
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony today thank you very much
I appreciate your your
input we have uh Robert Healey this is
representative
he it's actually Robert Healey
representative Robert Hy yep hey thank
you Mr chairman and thank you members of
the Judiciary Committee I am
Representative Bob Healey of Barac and
I'm speaking as a co-sponsor and in
support of House Bill
478 this was a bill that the late
speaker Dick hinch had on his list as a
priority for the citizens of
March March and the surrounding
communities including Bedford have been
dealing with the past contamination
issues in the areas surrounding the St
obain performance plastic facility since
2016 the contamination has been found in
our air soil groundwater and drinking
water that is supplied by the March
Village District better known as the
MVD we have had to deal with the wells
belonging to the MVD being shut down due
to high past contamination rates this in
turn causes issues especially in the
summer when the demand is high the MBD
has had to purchase water from other
sources to meet the demand which then
raises the cost of the water for all of
customers while St gobain agreed to pay
to filter the contaminated Wells the
price to filter the water from the MVD
Wells was over $5 million of which St
main paid just under 4 million leaving
the taxpayers on the hook for the
remainder also St gobain only agreed to
pay for a portion of the future
operation of Maintenance costs of the
water at treatment system which is
limited to the first five years of the
operation there's a reason the PS are
called
forever chemicals P does not degrade
easily and own only on very high
temperatures about
1825 degrees Fahrenheit unless actively
remedied pasas will continue to
contaminate our soil in water for years
into our future our children's future
and grandchildren's future as well as
our great grandchildren future as stated
in the text of the bill the POA
contration at Wells four and five has
measured in excess of 100 pots per
trillion the halflife of pooa in water
is greater than 95 years the decrease of
the current pooa concentration will
require approximately three lives or 300
years to reduce from 100 to 50 which
still exceeds the current mcl's of 12
pots per trillion agreeing to pay only a
portion of the future operation and
maintenance cost for only five years the
equivalent of a blink of an eye when you
look at it from the perspective of how
long a contamination will last you may
ask yourself self it's important and
shouldn't the customers and Ray payers
just pay for it the the customers of
marac Village districts didn't pollute
the soil and the water per New Hampshire
Dees St Goan is responsible that being
the case requiring St Goan to pay for
the filtration the operation and the
maintenance is fair and Common Sense
solution to take this burden off the
customers and the citizens located in
marbec and Bedford and to resolve the
public health hazard to refresh your
memories researchers finding these
forever chemicals are causing more and
more harm to people they have found
potential adverse of health effects
associated with past exposure including
liver damage thyroid disease decreased
fertility high cholesterol obesity
horomone suppression and cancer again I
speak in favor of House Bill 478
today thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions for
representative
he see none thank you very much thank
you
unmute okay you're on hi can you hear me
can I apologize Mr chairman thank you
very much for hearing me uh through you
and to the ranking member and the
members of your committee my name is
Bill Boyd I'm the vice chairman of the
marac Town Council and I'm here today on
behalf of the Town Council to speak in
support of House Bill
478 the the Town Council has sent in a
letter to you previously expressing our
support my testimony here today is
seeking to amplify that particular
letter letter that was sent to you under
separate cover there are three specific
points that I would like to or two two
specific topics that I'd like to get
into first off is the settlement
agreement between Sango ban and MBD for
as it relates to lws four and five which
is an agreement that occurred in
February
2018 on on April 1 Dees had issued a
letter to S to Sango ban mandating that
they pay for ongoing operation and
maintenance of posos treatment at all of
of nbd's public Supply Wells and at that
particular Point Dees and the AG's
office chose not to issue a descent
excuse me a consent decree against Sango
ban as it relates to that
contamination MBD as a consequence was
required to negotiate its own settlement
agreement with Sango ban without the
assistance of Dees or AG that settlement
agreement requires Sango ban to pay for
a portion of posos treatment MBD Wells
four and five but it only requires
Sangle ban to pay for the what what I
you know the the Gak the media the
filter media change outs that's only
paid for for five years and it's
important to note that it's only five
years that they're paying for that for
that particular maintenance piece
consequently the refusal of Dees to
issue a consent decree on mb's behalf is
the in is the inconsistency that House
Bill H uh HB 478 is seeking to
correct secondly the state the state
agreement consent decree negotiated by
the state with sang go Baine in 20 in
March of 2018 as it relates to the
private relates to the effective private
Wells which were excluded from the
original consent
order one of the things that they
developed was a groundwater management
Zone otherwise known as a gmz and it
delineated both parties and it also
included areas not just marac but it
include also included the communities of
Manchester Lichfield and Bedford two gmz
boundaries were Del were delineate one a
preliminary inner boundary and an out of
boundary which limited the extent of
Sango Ban's responsibility Sango ban is
required to mitigate all posos
contaminated private Wells within the
pegmc area please keep in mind what's
not mentioned is that MVD Wells four and
five are inside that preg GMC in most
boundary similar to the private Wells
required to be regulated one of the
things that that private well consent
degree did was to provide bottled water
with private Wells to people with
private Wells within that preg
gmz they were able to pay for an
extension in connection to private Wells
for available Public Water Supplies if
if I know you folks have been paying
attention to L field benefited from
connections with penetr water supply and
then part of the other thing was to pay
for future private Wells to be
determined level the contamination and
to determine whether or not is a is a
point of entry treatment and you know uh
home filter is going to be beneficial or
whether or not they need to be hooked up
to to private to a to a public water
supply EXC excuse me so at the end of
the day what what all this means is that
Sango Bain is obligated at least from
from my perspective is obligated to pay
for the point of entry treatment
including the change out of the of the
fil of the filter media because Dees
chose not to issue a consent order
regarding the contaminations that means
after five years those chain those
change outs are now going to be the
responsibility of the rate of the rate
of of of the private well owners and MVD
the uh the rate pay is to MVD for Wells
four and five MVD customers are going to
be paying to treat M these Wells for a
very long period of time so why should
MBD customers be required to pay to
treat something that is the
responsibility of someone else and in
this case edly Sango ban as I stated
initially MVD Wells 4 and5 the subject
of HP 478 are located within the preg
gmz boundary just like the private Wells
are again the same also applies to them
why should they be paying for their own
treatment at the end of the day from my
from my perspective a regulatory flow
exists within the laws whereby DS and
and the AG's office really did not or
could not act on behalf of of MD MBD
customers by being able to negotiate a
con a consent agree for Wells 4 and five
so subsequently this is an opportunity
to correct that regulatory floor I thank
the chairman and the committee members
for the opportunity to present and I'm
happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr Boyd
representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman um Mr Boyd I
I have to begin by saying that I am in
awe of the knowledge um and the degree
that you and your colleagues um go into
this issue and so forgive me for asking
a very naive question um that's okay
representative Smith thank you very much
that makes me feel better
um I'm I'm one I have two one question
but there kind of two parts to it one
again and again and again in the
Hampshire we have cities and towns
expressing annoyance at the state for
getting involved in what cities and
towns see as
their prerogative to make decisions
about what happens in their
communities and here I see quite the
opposite that you you really want the
state to get in and kind of take over uh
directing Sano go about what they have
to do and the other side of that is I
hear you saying that the
department
um refused to take
steps that you think might have helped
resolve the issue and of course while
we're the legislative branch we really
are pretty closely related to the
executive branch and all of that comes
together for why don't you see the
resolution as going to the third branch
to the judicial branch to resolve these
differences does that make any sense to
you Mr Boyd absolutely and I and I made
three quick notes so representative says
thank you than you so much for the
question I do appreciate it the the
state if the state can't get involved
because they don't have the tools to get
involved then that that they're only
follow they're only playing by the rules
by what is handed down to them
legislatively or what gets communicated
through them and and again I'm not
familiar with how things operate up in
conquer but you know the JL cars uh
committee is obviously responsible for
you know any legislation that's signed
into law and is promulgated forward it's
them that creates the rules for those
particular laws and Dees can only
operate within within those particular
parameters so you know that that's
number I don't for me from where I said
I'm not sure it's a ref refusal which is
why I said it's it's it's a the proposed
legislations to correct the flaw it's
it's the ability to be able to to have
that particular impact number
two I am just so you know as as a town
counsel I am very much a local control
kind of person I want my town to be able
to self-determine and decide what are
the things that we need to be resolving
to maintain and promote our quality life
here in March this why we this is why
the town of March filed for injective
relief in Hillsboro Superior Court in
Department the department of of
Environmental Services ironically had
filed suit uh earlier in that particular
day but we we chose to take the bull by
the horns because the facts was the
facts and the data were certainly on our
site to seek injunctive relief at at the
court level if if we have if we have the
ability to issue building permits you
know talking about just talking in
general and if somebody doesn't follow
that building permit we have the ability
to enforce that that that person do what
they need to do to subscribe to that
same building permit it's it's the same
concept with sang gobain if we tell sang
gobain to cease and assist because they
have met the rules of what's going on in
town and they ignore us we H we have to
go we have to ask the state say can you
can you join us because we're not
getting the relief we're not getting the
remedy from this particular individual
in our community who's not choosing to
listen to us and is not choosing to play
by the rules so at at the end of at the
end of the at the end of the day um as
it relates to this particular bill in in
light of your question you know we're
just trying to make the rules fair for
every
body thank you does that make sense
representative thank you very much for
your response I appreciate it thank you
any other questions Mr buy
representative
Langley thank you Mr chair for taking my
question and thank you Mr
Boyd I have some anxiety about asking
this question but I I need to put it out
there running between the towns of um
miramac and londondary is um no l yes
londondary in Mar Lichfield in lond
excuse me is the marac river correct and
I'm wondering has that been tested and
for uh runoff from some of these Wells
are just the groundwater into the river
from the two sites that have already
been identified I appreciate your
question thank you very much uh
currently on Sango bang site they have
two testing Wells both of those testing
Wells continue to exceed the limits of
what the state has determined to be an
acceptable level of peos it's the the
last number that I saw and I'm probably
going to cause my assistant DBW director
a little bit of uh indigestion but I
think it was you know 1500 to 2,000
parts per trilon were found in those
particular it was found in those
particular testing Wells um one of the
things that we' we we've asked you know
and and as you're familiar with our ms4
storm water permit you know that's one
of the things that the town is concerned
that there may be addition additional
cost as a result of that particular
cleanup so circling you know based on
the evidence that has been communicated
the probability of posos running off of
Sango Bain's property into testing Wells
into groundwater um and then you know
percolating up and moving moving south
into the MRE is very prevalent it it is
happening to what levels I don't I have
not seen I haven't seen a report on on
posos levels in the mar MC rer for a
couple years and I know when when this
when the onset of this occurred problem
occurred back in 2016 they were
identifying levels of posos in the marac
re thank you Mr boy you're
Bo yes representative De
Lorenzo
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr Boyd
for taking my question seems like there
are a lot of layers here and it's really
hard to figure out um you know who's
going to carry the ball on this and my
thought is had has the um Town contacted
issue the short answer is
no and may I follow up May is there a
reason why you the town has not
contacted the EPA since it sounds as if
um you couldn't get satisfaction from
Dees or the Attorney General's office I
I think if I would and I'm not trying to
be I'm not trying to be Ki
representative um that what you're
asking could constitute being part of
the town's legal strategy and I
certainly would not want to offer a
statement that may compromise any legal
you
if if I could ask Mr Boyd were were you
involved in the negotiation of the
contract with the fiveyear limitation no
I was not that MVD is a separate utility
from the town of
meramac and it was it was under their
office that the contract was
negotiated thank you you're
welcome any other
questions seeing that again thank you
for your testimony today Mr chairman to
the and to the the committee thank you
proventure hello yes we can hear you
great thank you um I just have a quick
um statement to present uh my name is uh
Donald preventure I am a professional
civil engineer bachelor in civil
engineering from UNH master in and Geo
environmental engineering from UMass LEL
uh I'm also president and founder of
preventure engineering which specializes
in water supply engineering for 20 years
um with that experience I ran for and
was elected to uh the Board of
Commissioners at MBD in March of
2018 and I've been chair for that um
commission for the last two years I've
become intimately familiar with the
history of nbd's involvement with st
gobain and the settlement agreement at
Wells 4
and5 however despite that I am here
today to explain that MBD will have a
notable absence in today's
participation and that's not due to a
lack of interest but is due to advice
from our legal councel to not proceed or
provide testimony today uh in an effort
to avoid potential legal retribution by
SLE ban for doing so um I do trust that
this committee will listen carefully and
consider all testimony presented from
all
parties uh and in future deliberations
on this bill uh but I will remain
engaged in this in this Zoom meeting and
available to provide any facts or
clarification needed today or later
pursuant to next week's executive
session
deliberations um and I've submitted this
uh written testimony or written
statement uh so you do have my contact
information um if you have any questions
I sent that to the house Judiciary
Committee at legislative state. n.
us um so if there are any questions I am
available um I do need to make sure that
I stay to just the um facts as I know
them to exist uh and I just wanted to
make it clear that I'm here um for the
for that purpose thank you are there any
questions from Mr
preventure yes representative walper
about I wasn't sure if I heard that all
quite
clearly I I think representative W was
asking what organization specifically
that you are associated with yes so I am
with uh I am the chair of the Board of
Commissioners of the meramac village
District that's MVD um MVD is the one
who negotiated the settlement agreement
with st gobain uh and that was prior to
my involvement with the board again I
was elected in March of 2018 and a
matter of fact the the night that I was
elected was the night that the
settlement agreement was announced by
the previous board members at the annual
MVD yes representative p
thank you Mr chairman um I'm going to
sound like
a broken horse or whatever but uh Mr
prent to the extent you can answer this
question is there anything that you know
now that you know St gobain knew that
the folks who entered the settlement
agreement on the TW 2018
date uh would have known would have
changed their mind had they known what
St gobain know
new so did you follow that and if you
can't answer for whatever reason but I
apologize I I yes thank I I I do
understand uh representative Paige
thanks for that question um I think the
the best answer I can provide is that um
I can relay a site visit that MVD
attended in HK
Falls um knowing that HK Falls was
building a granular activated carbon
treatment plant
um and they were involved in a similar
contamination uh situation in HK Falls
New York um some uh members of MVD staff
as well as our Consulting Engineers made
a visit uh over to HK Falls to speak
with the operators of that treatment
plant uh there there was a treatment
plant built um out there for uh the same
contamination as are experiencing so we
wanted to get some insight and when we
were at that um visit we asked the
representatives The Operators there that
were in the treatment plant some
questions about um what the cost is and
how frequently the media is changed and
their answer to us was that they didn't
have a lot of information specifically
because they actually didn't do the
filter change outs of the media that was
all done by St goban and St go Bain's
staff and everybody from MVD looked at
each other in astonishment because
nobody was aware that that was the case
um so upon further
questions uh and subsequently we had
this verified by our own uh legal staff
at the time uh we subsequently found out
that St gobain had been changing out the
media filters on their own cost as soon
as the first breakthrough of the first
past
compound um came through the
filters and that astonished look on the
face of the some of the members of MBD
who were present in part of that um
settlement agreement it that was a
complete surprise to them so I think
that that
surprise um that they are paying in HK
falls for the change out of that um
carbon filter media and have been paying
for that since we have since found out
since that went
online um in 2016 is a material
difference from what our settlement
agreement provides with only five years
of operation and
maintenance so that's one of the big
that's one of the big um unknowns that
we didn't know at the time apparently
thank you
representative
syvia thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my questions uh just
question just one uh are all aspects of
the settle settlement agreement
public yes absolutely that's all public
information and we can send that to
you are there any other questions for Mr
proventure I get I guess the the the
question I have is sort of a followup to
representative PA's question and and
that is if you've entered into an
agreement you've entered into a
settlement agreement with st
gbang and there are reasons why that
agreement could be nullified I think
representative Paige was sort of getting
there if there was a mutual mistake or
some type of
fraud U and and that might be a reason
for doing that and I'm presuming that
that might be one reason
why MBD is is not being forthcoming
because they have their own legal
strategy as to how they're handling that
and why why wouldn't we in considering
this bill wait to see if there is some
legal challenge to the validity of
agreement as opposed to taking some type
action uh I think the best way to answer
that is to um describe to you um the
outcome of a a meeting that was held at
the meramac Town Hall in November of
2019 um at that time um the late speaker
Dick hinch had requested a meeting um
upon my request there was a bunch of
questions that I had had regarding the
settlement agreement and um uh the late
speaker hinch had um called a meeting
with the governor the dees and the
Attorney General at the Town Hall in
November of 2019 and at that meeting
there were representatives from the Town
Council the MVD was there and some
representatives from meramac were in
attendance um the question was asked
about why did Dees not follow through on
their April 1st
2016 letter which uh requested that St
Goan provide treatment and and pay for
that
treatment um for all public water
supplies affected which was affecting um
MVD um and why did why did they not
enforce that letter and basically we
were told at that time that um Dees did
not have
authorization to enforce that letter
because they cannot negotiate on behalf
of a private entity well MVD is still
considered a a public
entity um and basically under the
provisions of RSA
485 We Believe Dees does have authority
to have to enforce that April 1 letter
uh but at that meeting we were
essentially told by the dees that there
there's nothing more that Dees is going
to do for MVD in this matter and that we
were pretty much left on our own from
that point
forward
um so that's that's that's kind of the
the the answer to my question
basically any other questions for Mr
preventure see none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you we have David
Ker
there it is thank you all for having me
here uh my name is David career I am
director of public policy for the
business and industry Association of New
Hampshire I'm here to uh speak in
opposition to this bill uh because it is
bad public policy to alter these types
of agreements after the fact um this
sends a signal to businesses that New
Hampshire is not a business-friendly
place um and what's going to end up
happening is that businesses will be
less likely to cooperate in
negotiations if they uh you know feel
that if the outcome of the negotiation
doesn't um go as far as you know the
town people wanted while they're just
going to legislate a new negotiation or
a new agreement uh with that business so
the less likely to uh cooperate in those
negotiations and will end up uh you know
litigating cases fully which will only
delay any remediation uh for you know
towns and situations like this um also
this will because it's sending that
signal of being a um nonb
business-friendly State uh businesses
will start to look elsewhere to either
expand or move their business uh which
can have serious detrimental effects on
our economy uh happy to answer answer
any questions that you may have there
any questions for
Mr represent mlan good thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so one of the one of the things
that was discussed is they're getting a
lot of feedback from Dees the dees felt
that they they did not have the
authority to enforce elements of of the
agreement if I understand that correctly
so um would the Bia be open to going
back rather than having a specific car
out of this specific settlement to look
at are there areas that are maybe murky
that need to be clarified and look at
that is that something you'd be willing
to look at in terms of the the agreement
you mean going back and look at that you
know in in terms of on a broader scale
just looking at those areas of the law
where Dees feels they're hamstrung and
don't have the ability to act oh okay I
see um well without seeing any language
you know it'd be hard for me to take any
specific position on a bill like that um
you know Bia has a pretty extensive
policy uh policy decision process uh
where we you know speak with our members
and we have committees um and hold
roundtables and and you know it's a
pretty extensive process of uh making
these policy decisions so unfortunately
I wouldn't be able to you know commit
one way or another with without seeing
any specific language and and running it
through that
process thank you any other questions
for
Mr Sing done thank you for your
testimony today thank you very much uh
Nancy
Murphy see
y
she hello hello can you hear oh great
thank you um good afternoon Mr chairman
and honorable committee members my name
is Nancy Murphy and I'm a resident of
marac I'm here to voice my support for
HB 478 and to respectfully request your
support as well um this bill is not only
important to those of us in the town of
marac served by the our local Municipal
Water Supply system the marac Doge
District but to MVD rate payers in
Bedford as well to better understand why
there's no need for a legislative
solution it's important to know a bit of
the history that has made this bill
necessary um as you know in early 2016
the marac community um with a population
of around 27,000 residents was first
informed that our public drinking water
was contaminated by pest many private
Wells were found to be contaminated as
well Dees identified St gobain as the
polluter manufacturing processes that
led to pasas releases via a deposition
and other pest discharges from the St
gobain facility resulted in Regional
groundwater contamination former Dees
assistant commissioner clar frzy shared
that the extent of this Southern New
Hampshire area contamination made it the
largest environmental industrial
disaster in New Hampshire's history
though all six of our wells are
contaminated MBD public Wells four and
five are located closest to the sovan
facility and they were shut down as the
P levels alone exceeded the federal
health advisory for p and posos these
Wells are situated within the
preliminary groundwater management Zone
agreed to S Cain and Dees in a March
2018 consent decree MBD Wells for five
required pfest filtration or treatment
before they could be put back online a
science-based knowledge Rel as as
science-based knowledge um relative to
the toxicity of past and po potential
risk from exposure to these chemicals
grew the EPA lowered its Health advisory
to 70 parts per trillion and on July
23rd 2020 hb1 1264 was enacted and set
health-based enforcable drinking water
standards on mcls for four past though
not responsible for the past
contamination of Wells 4 and five the
MVD will be required to comply with the
2020 drinking water mcls that have been
signed into law and provide safe
regulation compliant drinking water to
all MBD customers some of whom are
actually former private contaminated
well owners who have now been connected
to the MBD as part of the dees s gobang
consent decree given the highest
concentrations of past and Wells four
and five and the biopersistence of pest
it will take hundreds of years until the
pooa concentration at Wells 45 will be
reduced to the current 12 parts per
trillion MCL um I'd like to address the
issue of who should be holding stco Bane
accountable and I think this is part of
the challenge and what has necessitated
HB
478 um a letter dated April 1st 2016
with the subject heading regarding pfoa
matters in Southern New Hampshire was
sent by Dees commissioner Thomas Buck to
Mr Edward canning St gobain director of
environment health and safety at his New
York address this five-page letter
references quote a number of critical
steps that need to be taken immediately
to address the threats to Public Health
and the environment imposed by PFC
contamination and provided a three-page
list documenting actions that needed to
be taken by Sinco Bain DS uh Dees made
it clear in that letter that had an
expectation of prompt cooperation by Z
gobain in addition to site remediation
on page three the section most important
and relevant to this legislation appears
as it say cites the steps at St Goan
needs to take relative to public water
supply treatment it specifically lists
the design installation operation and
monitoring of all water treatment
systems necessary to effectively treat
and remove PFC
contamination from all affected water
systems and that St gobain will quote
provide for the necessary long-term
operation maintenance and monitoring of
the installed treatment
systems though Dees had issued this
April 1st 2016 letter to CCO Bain it did
not nor did the AG take action to issue
a consent order against anco ban
regarding contam mintion of Marin
Village District Wells 4 and five the
expectation that St gobain provide the
aforementioned long-term operation
maintenance and monitoring reference
within the letter though stated was not
enforced that's what made it necessary
for the MVD to negotiate its own
settlement agreement with st Cain
without Dees or the Attorney General's
assistance and I just wanted to I know a
couple of comments came up about who was
involved and um I think it should be
noted that there was no um uh Community
involvement there was no input sought
from community members who were aware
and were concerned about this issue um
that was a pro an agreement that was
made by a former group of uh elected
officials to the MVD um it's interesting
to note that a very similar scenario had
played out with Senco Bank contaminating
uh our our MVD public drinking water
well had occurred in New York just two
years prior in 2014 St gobain and
Honeywell International jointly
contaminated municipal
at the Village of HK Falls New York via
air emissions past deposition and
subsequent aerial groundwater
contaminated contamination resulted just
as it did in March similar situation
same polluter but what happened next is
quite different our state's response was
different which led to the need for HB
478 now in January 2016 New York's
Governor announced an emergency
regulation to classify pfoa as a
hazardous substance and the S gobain
mcaffrey plant as a state superf fund
site New York's Department of
Environmental Conservation or de issued
an order of consent and administrative
settlement which was signed in June 2016
naming s gobain and honwell as
respondents and mandating that St go
gobain there comply with what is being
asked here within
478 um DEC required that St gobain
provide uh design construction and
maintenance of pel filtration for the
village there and it was to be online by
uh June excuse me by December 2016 and
to pay for the long-term operation
maintenance and monitoring of those PS
filters uh this was all within months of
um us finding out about uh our
contamination
here pardon we have much more um oh
golly just maybe maybe another minute if
you're yeah and if you're reading it we
can can read your testimony going to
submit your testimony what we really
need to do is hear from you individually
yeah um okay I I'll I'll try to finish
up uh we understand here in marac that
we're not New York but given the the
consent letter there and the the
commissioner's letter here made the same
expectations of the same polluter for
doing the same thing to the public water
supplies of our their host towns we
would have hoped for a a more similar
State uh response and have had a similar
outcome um the
the challenges B uh that Dees has seemed
to believe that they haven't had the
ability to um act as we would have hoped
they would be able to um and the concern
is if Dees doesn't have that Authority
then you know I would certainly suggest
that it needs it um that this is making
their job difficult as well as the
experience of p uh P impacted citizens
and communities uh here um I I I'm I'm
hoping that that a legislative response
will um negate the the need for further
litigation we're five years into this um
the uh as as people have spoken before
me have suggested um this PS
contamination is causing costing us more
than just money uh Health impacts and
we're paying for contaminated water to
come through our faucets as well as uh
trying to purchase filtration systems
for our eles buying bottled water Etc um
it's time to prioritize the protections
of people above profits um thank you for
your time and attention and I and I ask
that you please consider voting OTP on
HB 478 thank you other questions from
his
word seeing none thank you for your
testimony
Pratt
hello hello okay thank you you can hear
me thank you for the opportunity to
provide some information again um my
name is Keith Pratt I'm a professional
engineer and president of Underwood
Engineers uh we have offices in forsman
and Conquer in fact we're just a few
blocks away from the house um we've been
providing water and wastewater
engineering New Hampshire for about 40
years and 14 of those have been in
meramac uh we're currently designing six
treatment plants in New Hampshire
including the three p fast facilities in
meramac and and a past facility in Dover
um Underwood was involved uh with the
planning and the design of all the
documents related to the pfest
facilities in
marac I personally was present many of
the meetings between San and and marac
as the settlement agreement was being
developed primarily to provide tech
support um I was requested to be here
because of our understanding of the
project so I'm volunteering my time
really to summarize the costs um of the
facility including the omm so we were
there and um when pest was first
reported at Wells four and five in
February 2016 and again you know when
the wells were shut down that spring and
by uh 200 by May of that year within
three months we'd actually developed our
first planning document to look at the
costs and within 16 months we had uh 30%
pfast treatment facility plant designed
which is actually what's what's in place
today uh but even though at that time it
was really an emerging issue with very
little industry knowledge it was that
30% design that became the basis of and
actually is attached to the agreement
that was uh executed March of 18 and the
cost opinions of um that were used in
that agreement um in that report were
were thought to be that the facility
would cost $4.4
million uh in September later that year
there was a meeting held at Dees the
request to St Cain with representatives
from all parties and uh and the outcome
of that meeting that the costs were
reduced uh essentially because it was
thought by S Bain and their experience
at other facilities I think HK Falls
primarily that that the costs beinged
were too high and further during the
settlement agreements the uh
negotiations the S Cain had um had
identified that of the portions 4.1 that
were related to three fast past was
around 3.3 million which is really Le
about a million dollars less than the
estimated cost to the to complete the
facility and actually now that the
project is is complete um the costs are
for the capital um and design phase and
everything else has come in right around
4.9 million which actually doesn't
include some of the preliminary costs um
up to that date we had also developed
onm cost in
2017 uh we estimated that the facility
would cost about
215,000 of which about half was thought
to be past
related and is which which is what sank
Bain agreed to pay only the past related
cost and and um despite attempts to get
more onm during the during that time the
final agreement has been noted earlier
that is is that they'd only pay five
years of the uh of the P related costs
or just over half a million uh just over
$500,000 um and at that time we believe
that the the carbon which is the media
that removes the past would last two
years um three years later now that we
have more experience uh more knowledge
and new regulations uh we actually
believe that the media will be replaced
every year and probably closer to
potentially every six months we're also
finding that the cost to the media is
more expensive as well these two things
have really significantly impacted the
cost the onm cost uh we now believe MBD
is facing past related onm cost for
Wells 4 and five in the range of 100 to
106 60 to
$450,000 per year or 50 to 400% more
than what we thought at the time of the
settlement
agreement uh the wide range really still
considers uh the many uncertainties we
have with past treatment as well so over
the next 20 years we're projecting that
CCO Bain's portion represents about 6 to
177% of what we now believe the actual
past on andm cost will be um the cost to
MVD over 20 years we're projecting to be
between 2.6 or 8.5 million for oper
ations so after four and a half years um
of the wells being offline the good news
is the facility is working the plant
went online four months ago and is
currently producing water with no
detection of past the bad news is the
capital cost and significantly more than
what was anticipated and the operation
costs are uh as well so uh hopefully
that helps just at least put some
perspective on the on the magnitude of
cost and I'd be happy to answer any
questions and thank you thank you very
much for your testimony representative
Chase
can you hear me all right we can hear
you excellent It's About Time thank you
for taking my question and if you're not
the right one maybe somebody can help me
with this so as I'm sitting here
listening and I'm
uh very concerned about the water safety
and what what could happen in the future
where there is this town Hosk Falls in
New York and there's been a state a
state walk and we're finding out all
this
information is there some type of an
agreement that the marrat can look at
that um hosek Falls has with s Kain and
how they how long they're going to be
helping them and changing these uh
filters and you know if there's already
agreement and and there was a little bit
of of concern that maybe they took
advantage of maram residents because of
the heightened problem that first
started when it was
approached can it just be reviewed and
looked at and maybe us some of the
language or some of the the um the the
follow through with maybe I'm assuming
it's an insurance company who's paying
this and now be able to put that into
the
marac
needs you get does that make sense get
that question Mr Pratt I'm yes thank you
for the question and I and I understand
and I can't speak to the document itself
but I do know the document exists and I
do believe the marac has a copy of that
document there is an agreement between
sanco ban and the parties associated
with the HK Falls so that does
exist okay I guess that's there any
other questions from Mr
Pratt seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you okay and there
is a uh we have three more people who
pre- registered to testify all
testifying in support of the legislation
Allen hi can you hear me you can well
thank you so much for hearing or plea
and I must say I feel really bad that
your heads are exploding with what we
and meramac have been dealing with since
2016 I know this is complex I know
there's a lot of layers and I do
understand what you're trying to do here
and your job in determining if you are
the place to deal with this or it should
be pursued privately I hear that as I'm
listening so for the record my name is
Loren Allen I have been a resident of
meramac since
1985 uh I am a co-founder of a citizen
group that I never set out in life to do
uh but myself and other members of the
community uh became very concerned in
2016 over um something that pertains
specifically to this bill what we would
expect to be happening and what we'd
expect to see moving forward given
discovery of contamination of public
water and what we were actually seeing
so we have done a lot of work as a
community we have done a lot of advocacy
and we have taken on roles that we never
thought we would so this bill um was
brought about by citizen initiative um
the late representative hinch graciously
and you know beautifully tuned into this
issue and met many many occasions with
our citizen group we also invited Town
Council Members commissioners of the MVD
public at large um elected officials our
state senators even our federal
delegation so we've had community
meeting in sitdown after sitdown so the
long and short of it is back in
2016 um you've heard several people
testifying referring to this letter that
Dees set out you know basically laying
out there expectations of s gobain to uh
make right the situation at Wells 4 and
five uh so we believe that was to be
happening and what happened in this
process is there were supposed to be
some temporary filters that were
supposed to actually come to New
Hampshire from HK Falls New York this is
what kind of got us involved with HK
falls in the first place and we're like
wh what's that about turns out HK Falls
shares a a polluter with us and S oain
had immediately installed a temporary
filter system until they could install a
permanent one which they have done and
we were told that these filters were
coming to miramac very shortly and a
month went by two months went by six
months went by in the meantime what
happened is we didn't know they were
getting you know their negotiation push
back with HK Falls was getting a little
tense and um I think what was going on
there was kind of fueling the resolve on
this end as s go Bain you know a
multi-billion dollar international
corporation if you just look them up and
see how many dots they have on the map
in New England and North America alone
it's immense um so you know I'm a
business owner in New Hampshire and I do
understand liability is part of what we
do have to consider you know in every
business whether large or small like my
own so I I do understand this on their
point of view is about liability um you
know control and I firmly believe that
in restricting this agreement and
limiting it to the five years they feel
that you know it's no acknowledgement of
harm they're doing it in good faith and
then boom they can wash their hands of
it so their ultimate goal is not to be
responsible for damages or medical
claims or medical monitoring clearly for
years you know these chemicals cause a
Havoc of health issues they play out
through the lifetime decade after decade
and you know if if we were to uh you
know be granted uh Health monitoring or
something like that you know this is
this is a can of worms here we have
25,500 members of the miramac community
who use MVD water so let me step back
for a second and I don't know how many
of you have driven up and down Dani
Webster Highway ever so we have kind of
SLE Bane in the northeast corner of
meramac uh behind them is the meramac
river they're on Dani Webster Highway if
we travel South on that road a bit in
between Seno Bane and well Wells four
and five Wells four and five are due
south of s gobain you know I don't have
to be a hydrogeologist to know which way
water flows I've I've kayaked and canoed
and understand rivers and Brooks and all
that stuff so in between Senco ban I
don't want to short but I you know we've
got it we've had I think we've got
filled in you know with a with all the
other testimony we've had with regard to
the pollution and the effect those
things well we I think what we really
need to address or focus on at this
point in time
is why the legislature should get
involved time with what was a private
contract in the past I'll give you my
pitch I gotcha so um two issues were
raised somebody earlier in this hearing
one one of your Comm Comm members raised
the issue of um shared responsibility I
thought that speech was very interesting
because what he stated was very similar
to what s gobain argued back in 2016
which is why the negoti s for MVD in St
gobain went behind closed doors they
asked for a closed door uh mediation
process the public was not happy none of
us the Town Council the Town members
because we no longer got to be privy to
what was being decided that impacted us
every day so what happened is they went
into that mediation process or
Commissioners are no longer in office
they were members of the public they
were older gentlemen at that point they
were being told Nothing by the state of
the federal government as the qualities
of these chemicals they didn't really
know anything and they were assured um
that they could handle this the state
kind of backed out and left them to it
so it really isn't right so at this
point uh the settlement agreement that
they they finally did after two years uh
one of the Commissioners when he retired
said to me I feel really bad at this
point because we know so much more but
we couldn't we couldn't get anything
else agreed to we just couldn't so
there's been Avenues looked at someone
earlier talked about meeting with uh the
governor actually the governor the um
Assistant Attorney General and Dees
meeting to look at what we have for
recourse um we have asked you know
environmental Attorneys at a Citizens
group uh we took citizens initiative
because this is the only Avenue we have
we have no legal recourse whatsoever to
enter to look at this agreement MVD
cannot Advocate they cannot go to court
and say hey we have more information now
and we want this looked at what you have
suggested here are very good suggestions
and we as a community have looked at
those uh venues for many many years and
unfortunately none of them are possible
EPA region one um is aware of or wo
we've met with them on several occasions
what they have stated to us is your
state has the authority uh we have um is
it RSA for the Clean Water 485 I believe
it is uh that RSA that someone referred
to I don't have the number because it's
similar to this one uh gives them the
authority the state has the authority so
um the assistant Commissioner of Dees uh
who has since retired said to us in a
community meeting uh when we posed that
question to him we said EPA says you
have the authority to do whatever we
need and whatever it takes he said well
we technically do but here in New
Hampshire we don't like to overstep we
have a good partnership and working
relationship with businesses I
understand that he said we can get
further that way by litigation and it's
cheaper I understand that also um I
understand his point of view he said but
uh we're not going to take action unless
we're legislated to do so that was a
very very clear statement that was made
to our community on many many occasions
so the long and short of it is you know
forever chemicals the wells are just
south of s goane the numbers have gone
up on-site numbers on slean 69,500 part
per trillion pfoa alone in their
groundwater in their ground monitoring
Wells on their site just north of two of
our public Wells so after five years we
bear the cost of this as taxpayers and
residents forever and they're basically
off the hook so that that's really why
we're coming to you here we really
understand you're in a tough situation
but we truly do not have a reason
legitimately to file for reasons uh to
nullify maybe a citizen group could I'm
not really sure how to do that but the
mvds hands are tied uh thank you thank
you very much are there questions from
miss
alen seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today and again we're down to the last
Thomas
okay uh Mr chair and esteemed members of
the Judiciary Committee I am former
state representative Wendy Thomas from
marac and I come before you in support
of HB 478 which is a bill that enforces
adequate and fair restitution from an
industrial polluter towards those who
have been adversely affected there are
three points of this bill that I'd
specifically like to address Point
number one the history of the MV VD s
CCO Bain settlement agreement for MVD
public Wells 4 and5 which was signed in
February of
2018 the MVD s Coan settlement agreement
for MVD Wells 4 and5 was signed by both
parties in February
2018 it was based on a preliminary
treatment design a preliminary treatment
plant
construction along with the operation
and maintenance cost estimates developed
in 2016 and
2017 that information is specific to the
two parties and to MVD Wells four and
five only the cost and other information
used in that settlement agreement from
2016 to
2017 was sub subsequently found to be
inaccurate and
underestimated MVD needed to enter into
settlement negotiations with st Cain
because
nhdes failed to take action to compel
Senco Bain to pay for all of the
necessary long term operation
maintenance and monitoring of the
installed treatment systems as demanded
in the dees letter to S gobain on April
1st
2016 Point number two that I'd like to
address concerns that passing HB 478
will set a precedent that any settlement
agreement can be changed by the
legislature the uniqueness of this
agreement resulting from de's failure to
take enforcement action to is unique to
this case
this uniqueness has no bearing on any
other settlement agreements and would
therefore not set any precedent that
they that the New Hampshire legislature
can overturn any other settlement
agreement brought
forward this bill hb7 uh 478 was modeled
after a similar Bill HB 494 which
compelled the kley landfill group to
work with the dees to reach a consent
degree to design and implement certain
groundwater remediations Associated
costs and to establish a timetable to
implement
remediation if Dees had taken
appropriate enforcement action pursuant
to the dees letter to Senco Bain on
April 1st
2016 and if Dees would have compelled s
Cain to pay for all of the necessary
long-term operation maintenance and
monitoring of the installed treatment
systems as demanded in the letter there
would be no need for this legislative
action this bill is similar oh MBD has
exhausted all other reasonable a Avenues
to seek the restitution demanded by Dees
in its a in its April letter to Senco
bang MBD has met with the governor the
AG and Dees and was incorrectly advised
by Dees that they had no authority to
compel St Cain to pay for all of the
necessary long-term operation
maintenance and monitoring of the
installed treatment systems because Dees
claimed it had no authority to negotiate
on behalf of a village District MVD
participated in and paid their
consultant Underwood engineering uh
Underwood Engineers Incorporated to
update incorrect long-term operation and
maintenance costs and negotiate with
sanco Bain a second time to provide
additional costs that should and would
have been fully covered if Dees had
enforced its April 1st 2016
letter my last point point three is that
this bill HB 478 will provide an Avenue
like the kley landfill Bill to correct
deficiencies by a responsible party and
to require taking the necessary actions
required by
Dees although this bill would current
currently help MVD it is important to
have it in place so that if or when
another town or water supplier is harmed
by contamination from a polluter and
that polluter is compelled to address
and provide remedial activities by Dees
but fails to do so or if Dees fails to
take enforcement action in follow-up to
a demand letter to a polluter for
remedial action that town or water
supplier will have an Avenue available
to them similar to HB
494 and HB
478 to compel the polluter to take
remedial action through an act of
legislation for these reasons I urge you
all to support House Bill
478 which would require adequate and
fair remedial action from an IND from an
industrial polluter towards those who
have been adversely affected please vote
OTP for this Bill thank you thank you
for your testimony representative are
question actually most I was just saying
that um I have I as I mentioned earlier
to you in the the ranking member I have
to leave early at three so it's now 302
so that's why I'm that's why I'm leaving
few
minutes so I thank representative thas
and everybody else who took time to
testify and thank you so just wanted
just didn't feel like sneaking out uh
sneaking out on it without acknowledging
that I'm leaving a little early which I
hate to do thanks thank you are there
any questions for representative uh
former representative
Thomas seeing none thank you for your
testimony today that concludes the list
unless there's somebody else who feels
compelled to testify
today and I don't see any
hands so that will end our hearing on
478 just just want to apologize I I
didn't think it was going to be an issue
this afternoon with regard to time
otherwise I would have set a time limit
at the beginning but didn't feel like
good in the middle of everything so um
in any event thank you for your patience
today we do have uh executive session on
the 10th at nine
o'clock uh everybody should be prepared
to be there because we do have a lot of
bills I think there's going to be 17 of
them all together that we need to act on
one way or the other
uh so if you can't be there please make
arrangements to have a substitute
there yeah yes you should
let let let uh the appropriate people
know in
advance in any event uh I hope you all
have a great weekend unless there's
something else any other issues you want
to
raise thank you so much thank you thank
you Mr chair thank you Mr chair have a
good everyone